ARR meeting thank
you thank you chair uh members as I
emailed out to you before the meeting um
just to be sure that um the windows are
open throughout the whole of the day
we're going to maintain social
distancing we've got our screens back up
up to protect you um everybody's asked
to leral flow in advance of attending at
the meeting and we're all going to keep
our masks on unless we're speaking I'm
I've kept mine own for the moment but
you don't have to when you're speaking
um but if you would be kind to keep them
on if possible um where you are not
exempt um whilst you are not talking
within the meeting thank you
chair thank you so item one on the
agenda today is apologies for
absence
thank you sh and we have apologies for
absence from councelor
Jones thank you I've got on my list that
Roger Hall is being sub substituted by
Steve cluf Jackie Ridgeway is being
substituted by Nigel
Barker David Hancock is present this
morning but will be substituted this
afternoon by Pam windley thank you are
there any other
apologies not received chair thank
you Declarations of interests the second
item is of Declarations of Interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
P interest and or other interest not
already on their register of
interest in any item on the agenda and
withdraw them from the meeting at the
appropriate time do any members have any
interest to declare councelor
Cooper yes chair
um my glasses on uh item
21885 FL the the one in pillsy decare an
interest I'll be taking my three minutes
but remaining in the chamber to listen
to the debate but not taking any part in
that debate thank you are there any
others no thank you very much item three
minutes of the last meeting we now have
the minutes of our meeting held on
Tuesday
16th of November 2021 are we happy that
they are a correct
record thank you all those in
favor any
against any
extensions the motion's been carried
thank
you main
business main business for today as you
can see we have six applications to
consider the first of three this morning
is appol followed by Clay Cross and
pilsley during the afternoon session we
will take in the killer Marsh and two
ashover applications as well as the
planning appeals report before we get
started I would like the Clark to
explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on YouTube
how we will doal with the
application thank you chair this is the
procedure for considering applications
this
morning we will consider the three
applications in the order that they are
set out on the
agenda the chair will introduce the
application then ask the planning
officers to refer members to any late
comments or updates received since the
agenda was
issued the late item's agenda supplement
has been published on the council's
website and hard copies have been
circulated to
you the planning officers will then give
a brief presentation setting out the
application plans and photographs from
the site
after this the chair will ask each of
the
speakers objectors then the applicant or
their agent to speak to the
committee each speaker will have three
minutes to put forward their
views there will be a reminder given by
the clerk when 30 seconds remain at the
end of a speaker's three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary to clarify any points have
made when we have heard from all the
speakers on an application the chair
will open up the meeting for debate by
the committee and determination by the
vote the votes will be taken by roll
call once the application which a
speaker has come to speak on has been
dealt with then they may leave the
meeting if they choose to remain then
they will not be allowed to participate
further in the meeting from that
point as you aware this this meeting is
being live streamed and a recording will
be placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
make a copy of it thank you
chair thank you we'll move on to the
business and our first application today
is Ned
sl201
slfl at appol and I'll ask the um
officer to lead us straight in thank you
chair
um yeah as as mentioned the application
is for the creation of a total of 40
parking spaces within the defined
settlement development limits for appol
um these will be for the use of
residents and visitors to the Village um
could I have the first slide
please sorry I can't see the slide SL is
can everyone else see
it Alan is anyone sharing the
screen uh Nikki are you able to share
screens I wasn't aware I've been given
the presentation be me a second I'm I
have the presentation I thought I was I
was sharing as it as it
[Music]
stands okay thanks
Adrien
okay thank
you apologies chair thought I was
sharing is that okay C that's perfect
yeah
thanks yeah so the um uh aerial photo
shows the broad um locations of the
proposed parking within the Village um
next slide
please similarly the location plan just
illustrates the um the proposed The
General locations of the proposed
parking um and just to to add to that
that um officers for the reason set out
in your report consider that the parking
spaces set out on these location plans
are acceptable um in accord with the
local plan policies and the national
policies that are applicable to this
this particular application next slide
please so this is the first layout plan
um detailing the
parking um for Quarry Road to the west
and to the southeast morland's view
where there's two parking allocations
comprising a total of 17
spaces um next slide
please the following slide this
illustrates the parking layout for
Sharman close and for new road to the
east um
and the following slide um will
illustrate the proposed materials that
these parking spaces will be surfaced
with so a resin bound surface and some
of the detail the technical details are
also specified there in terms of
permeability next slide
please um the first photo shows the
parking or or the site of the proposed
parking on New Road um on the verge to
the front of the the properties in in
the background there next photo
please this is a photo of Sharman close
um where there would be um the parking
allocations that you saw in the previous
layout plans next photo
please and this is also shaming close
this photo is just taken really to
illustrate the changing levels across
the S and you will no noticed in the
officer report that officers have
recommended that a condition be
imposed um for details of any
engineering and levels to be um
submitted to an agreed in writing by the
local Authority subsequent to a grant of
any Planning Commission on this site
next photo
please um this is the um site of the uh
car park at the end of morland's view
which would be um would comprise a total
of six parking spaces as seen on the
previous layout plan again there is a
change in levels across the site so
hence the uh the necess the necessity
for a levels condition um again this is
morland's few there will be a total of
11 parking spaces um to the front of the
building that you can see um in the
center of the picture next slide please
this is the final slide which shows the
parking allocations uh or or the the
site of the proposed parking sorry on um
on Quarry Road um so they would be on
the verge and again there is a change in
levels um across this site and that
concludes the presentation thank
you thank you are there any questions
for the officer councel
Armitage thank you chair this uh method
of making the uh actual uh parking you
know what it's going to be made of I've
seen this before and what happens is the
gravel that goes on the top washes out
and you're left with the uh plastic
pieces and then they start to lift now
is there enough underneath to stop these
lifting or are they straight onto the uh
clay or soil or whatever the is because
they do tend to be rather dangerous
especially when you've got frost and and
uh water on them uh car slide about on
them yeah thank you Council ritage um in
terms of the the level of knowledge of
the detail of those um surfacing
materials probably wouldn't have the an
answer to the question in terms of the
the technical specifications but we were
Guided by highways officers in terms of
the acceptability of the parking space
and the um the materials that were
detailed and highways officers have
raised no objections to that in addition
to that um there would be the potential
to require details up front of these
materials um but but but obviously we do
have some detail and we have concluded
that um those materials are acceptable
as I say Guided by the um comments of
darish County Council highways
offices any other question questions
councelor
Elliot thank you chair it's similar
actually to to what councilor Armitage
has said is it resin bonded or are these
the plastic type material where the
Grass Grows through it it's it's as far
as I'm aware it's resin bonded so it
would be um there wouldn't be any loose
material and the highways um based their
comments I think that's what councelor
Armes was alluding to that the would be
loose and come away but it doesn't it's
resin bonded isn't it yeah that's that's
my understanding that it wouldn't be
there wouldn't be any loose material um
to be um uh moved onto the highway as a
consequence of vehicle movements to and
from these parking spaces and it would
be a a material that is acceptable
ultimately to highways officers having
having given consideration to that yeah
that's fine thank
you any further questions thank you very
much
we have no speakers I believe on on this
application no so we can go straight
straight into a debate if there is
one if not we'll move straight to a
motion okay all those in
favor I think that's up if we we can
just do that up by show of
hands it's you know
thank
you thank you
all
okay okay second application which is
Ned
sl210
627 forl at playay Cross before we move
on I would like to point out because
there's been a lot of chatter and air
time over this that we are here to
determine the application in front of us
and that is all it is the amendment
thank
you say to the planning
officer thank you chair a can we have
the presentation on
please again shair I thought I was
sharing the screen is that
visible to
everyone not as
yet is that okay
Alan that's it a
yeah up the first slide
please
thank you um right this is an aerial
photograph of the site which has an
extent permission which is currently
under construction clay Lane lies to the
South to the West is windir Road whose
rear Gardens about the Press Brook which
runs next to the western side boundary
the trees on the western side boundary
with the brook are covered by a tree
preservation order have the next slide
please
this is the uh Redline site boundary
plan which is uh relates to the original
application
um next slide
please thank you uh this shows the
revised site layout which seeks minor
changes to Road alignment and plot
positions in the northwest corner and
also to the affordable units fronting
clay Lane the site levels are similar to
those already approved works on site
have begun and the levels in the
northwest corner have been raised to the
approved levels under the existing
permission the bottom of the plan shows
the highlighted Wildlife buffer with
press Brook which is the same as
approved under the original
permission the next slide
please
thank
you this shows a comparison between the
approved layout and the proposed layout
got the approved layout on the left hand
side and the proposed layout on the
right proposed layout generally brings
units away from the brook and only has
three Gardens directly adjacent rather
than the five on the extent permission
the western side boundary fence line is
the same same on both
layouts the affordable units front and
Clay Lane to the South have a slightly
revised orientation and garden
shape have the next slide
please this is a zoomed in extract of Po
layout which um plot 20 next to turning
head is in the same position on both uh
the section 73 and also the approved
layout yeah next slide
please this slide shows a proposed
Landscaping scheme with the additional
planting alongside the brook and next to
the affordable units at plot
21 proposed Landscaping is now
consistent with that already approved
under the extent
Commission
thank you uh this plan shows the
location and cross-sections of a relief
tank that has been proposed by the
applicant that's a photo um taken within
the site looking towards a northwest
corner the trees along the Press Brooker
in the
background
so another photo of the northwest corner
where plot 11 mongalo will be cited the
levels have been raised in accordance
with the original permission and the
relief tank would also be cited in this
location This Is A View From the
northwest corner looking East um the
northern side boundary lies to the left
of the
photo
it's a view looking South towards the
turning head and plots 19 and 20 the
trees and uh and press Brook are behind
the fence
line it's another photo looking South
back towards clay Lane and the Press
broke thank you chair
thank you and I believe we have four
speakers for this application and the
first one is councelor Ros
Shipman excuse me chair would you like
us to bring in the other speakers
now I think they're already here Alan
I've got facing me that's marvelous
chair thank you counc you have three
minutes thank you chair um I don't I
don't see how you can talk about about
this application without talking about
the original one because the legal
advice that's been sought off this new
one actually doesn't address The Wider
problem and that is that there's a flood
risk from the
development and DCC say that they
believe it still is which is why they've
also kept their concerns on the record
that the committee need to read and
understand because all along throughout
this development residents have been
promised that work will be done to
mitigate the flood flood risk but
actually it's been a f from start to
finish because that's never been done
and DCC are now accepting that by not
removing that comment of their uh
comments that they've put to this um
committee I think that the committee
can't pass this application today until
those flood risks are dealt with because
it's all well and good saying this
change of conditions doesn't alter the
risk but between how the land was
originally and this application now
there is an increased flood risk and
that's what that's why County want their
um hydraulic survey doing on on the uh
Brook and that's still not been done as
part of this application there's a
relief tank which takes I think 100
cubic meters that's nowhere near enough
to take it take the water load that that
previous flood plane used to hold and
that's why today the planning committee
need to actually look at that flood risk
aspect because it is part of this
application because they've put the
release tank in um another thing is that
the legal advice that the council sought
on this it doesn't actually say who is
responsible short houses on windir road
flood it talk it says that the district
council is not responsible but it
doesn't say who actually is at the end
of it and I think until the plan
committee know who will be responsible
if those ARS on wind Road flaw how can
this be passed because we know the
county have got it wrong the first time
around in the main application so how
can we trust that there is no additional
flood risk on this application just
because couns say there isn't and I
think that the district council really
need to find out who is going to be
responsible if those hours on windo
flood and until that's done I don't
think it can be passed today I'm
afraid are there any questions for
councelor
Shipman no thank
you so second speaker is Mark
Allan Mr Allen you have three minutes
when you're
ready in 1994 planning was refused on
this site for single bunglow due to the
risk of flooding planning committee
report dated the 15th of December
2020 paragraphs 2-4 on page 14 State
flooding in the area adjacent press
Brook is and always has been a major
problem in line with present conditions
it would seem that flood pres guidelines
are irrelevant and should be reassessed
and that building on the site will only
exagerate and contribute to the problems
already endured by the residents of
windir
Road document Ed d22 S SOG cc2 dated May
2018 section 2.3 following comments on
the consultation draft plan in
2017 including the environmental agency
the site boundary was altered to exclude
a strip of land which was in flood zone
3 section 5.1 DLP on behalf of wood
orone state that with careful layout the
site could yield 36 ohms yet the council
considered a yield of 25 ohms more
appropriate considering the requirements
for buffer
zone prior to the original planning
application being approved on the 19th
of May 2020 I submitted video and
photographic evidence showing the brook
with a water height of 1.26 M the LPA
failed to take notice of act and act
upon this for the revised application I
again submitted video and photographic
evidence showing the water he at 1.26 M
woodor loms contacted bsp consultant to
carry out a flood risk assessment of the
rook in line with government guidelines
who stated that the peak water height of
a one in 100e episode would be a height
of
0.919 meter this figure has been proven
to be inaccurate as I have submitted on
several occasions photographic evidence
showing the height 341 mil higher than
what the supposedly experts predict
would be a one in 100y year episode that
P's been exceeded four times in the last
two years which shows the experts are
wrong wood all homes have now raised the
embankment on the Eastern side of press
Rook which I believe will lead to
flooding along windir Road precedence
has been set in the case study John
Green versus Lord summer l
2003 based on the actual water Hees
measured compared to the theoretical he
given by bsp Consulting then our would
all both Northeast arire District
Council and wood all hes jointly liable
of cor corporate negligence as the
evidence was PRI provided prior to
building where commencing the government
white paper on planning states that
local residents
opin are there any questions for Mr Alan
Mr if you want to stay there till I
don't think there are any so please sit
down
okay next speaker is uh Richard
Eden you have three minutes Mr Eden when
you're
ready I will be objecting on behalf of
myself and most of the residents of
windir Road in conjunction to the
revised 73 planning application I spoke
in the original application meeting 12
months ago we gave photographic evidence
of the northwest corner in flood the
land a as a natural flood plane our
comments were disregarded and quoted as
he say we object to the revised plane
objection on the grounds that the
northwest corner has not been correctly
surveyed the developer has planed to
build a tank to take flood water from
press broke in heavy rain the tank will
not take the volume of water that the
flood plane did the the figures that
they have uh worked sorry the figures
they have worked from it are incorrect
and therefore puts further risk of flood
to the existing residents the new layout
will also impede on the wildlife buffer
zone that was agreed and affect trees in
the TPO the L LFA are not happy with the
figures and has advised the developer to
complete a topo geological hydrolic
survey which the developer has chosen
not to do
so I have watched this section of from
childhood slowly decreas in height due
to continued increasing and decreasing
of the water table to become a natural
flood plane and be become our safety net
in every rainfall the now raised land
will stop the water will not stop the
water table rising and decreasing the
houses will be built on concrete piles
but their Gardens and driveways won't
this raised land gives the potential for
SS to appear in time and mood slides
into press Brook we have now proved that
the land was lower than ours and was
flood plane was a flood plane and is in
flood zone 3 we are now at further flood
risk the llfa have objected to the
original plan the EA advised back in
March that a topo geological hydraulic
survey needs to be completed if there
were any concerns about flooding this
has not been completed the LPA legal
document clarifies it has it has put us
at further risk of flooding and that the
developer has Mis misled the LPA and the
llfa state the land was higher than
windir road we have no faith in the
developer who has misled had to put in
another revised application because the
onate sewer was not where they thought
it
was uh completed a flood rest survey on
figures that are not correct which is
not has been proven by the llfa I
believe the only way to rectify this is
to put a hold on this application till
the correct hydraulic survey is
completed I would also like to know what
mitigation action do the LPA plan now
they they know we're at further risk of
flooding due to the development and why
mppf legislation of flood risk was not
ad
to thank you are there any
questions thank you Mr Eden if you'd
like to take a seat
you our final speaker on this
application is Simon bets I believe is
the
agent three minutes Mr bets when you're
ready chair members of the planning
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak on behalf of the applicant I
would wish to make the following
observations firstly I would like to
reiterate and add to some of the key
elements from the committee report which
comprise essential context in informing
a decision on this application namely
this site is allocated for housing
within the newly adopted local plan and
is therefore part of the council's
committed housing land Supply position
this site already has the benefits of a
full planning permission for 34
dwellings with all pre-commencement
conditions having already been fully
discharged and a lawful commencement of
development having already taken
place the process for minor material
amendments exists to account for changes
as a result of the detailed design
process Andor site conditions
experienced
in this case in the applicant seeking to
implement the Planning Commission they
already have it relates the underground
location of a sewer being different to
the asset plans provided by the
statutary
Undertaker this generates the need for
minor revisions to the internal Road
layout and some of the plot positions
hence the application before you
today as such I would respectfully
comment that in the case of this
application it is essential that memb
members understand the terms on which
they can make a decision and issues
which are relevant and those which are
not whilst it is noticed that the
application has generated concerns in
relation to flood risk the minor
revisions for which permission is sought
do not introduce any material concerns
in relation to flood risk and all of
these works that the subject of this
application are within flood zone one
the lowest risk area as confirmed by the
council's own legal advisors this issue
cannot be given any material weight in
the consideration of this application
and to do so would I quote be
perverse in saying that in a response to
the issues raised in the discussion
today I will clarify that the applicant
has positively responded to the concerns
of the llfa throughout and is happy to
continue those discussions outside of
this
process as such I would urge members to
carefully consider the terms of this
application the fact before you and the
legal advice received by the council and
will welcome support of the officer
recommendation to Grant planning
permission thank you are there any
questions no thank you very
much are there any questions for the
planning
officer councelor hanock councelor
Elliott thank you chair um I am actually
going to refer to the flooding issues
because it is referred to in in the
report quite significantly I mean
several pages are dedicated to this it
does tell us um and I've got no reason
to doubt it that both the planning our
planning officers on the L
llfa suggest that there's no further
risk the key thing which occurs to me is
in
720 whereas it says as matters have
progressed it has become apparent that
the developers representation was
incorrect so what what you're telling us
on one hand is that there's no further
risk but the risk assessment is done on
information which was
incorrect now in in my head those two
things don't tie up so I don't see how
we can legitimately give a decision
either for or against when we're being
given contradictory information in a
report and we're being told that a
previous decision has been made on
information which is not right so
particularly I'd appreciate Jim I think
more than anyone giving us guidance on
that because to me that would be
negligent on
part yeah I think the
um what members need to look at here is
the um what is the application in front
of you the the application in front of
you is to make a minor material
Amendment to the road
layout so the question you need to ask
is what additional effect does that
material Amendment have on the um on the
flooding issue I I understand that there
are concerns about um what's happened on
the previous application however that
has now now gone you've now you've
approved that application so the the
issue here is quite
simply um does the um does what proposed
have any additional effect on the
flooding issue and I think
the question or um officers belief is
that no it doesn't it doesn't have any
impact whatsoever on the uh um flooding
as as it stands and therefore it would
be inappropriate for you to take into
account any um the the flooding um
considerations that took place before uh
so so what you have now is
um a a situation where there is no the
theate the The Proposal doesn't have any
impact or any additional impact on
flooding and that's the issue that you
need to
consider thank you you're happy with
that I just reply yes yeah yeah because
again I'm not really getting Clarity
here because um I mean one gentleman I'm
not I'm not going to um make the same
accusation because I don't know and I
wasn't on the planning committee when
this was originally heard but the term
misled has been used um our own report
from our officers says that that
information was
incorrect so we're being asked to make a
decision based on something that we are
being told was
wrong so that that's that's my concern
it's it's a case that that we're being
said that we we're assessing something
against something which is
incorrect that's our
terminology to me that the two things
just can't we we can't give a legitimate
decision when we know that something's
wrong um I'm not arguing for or against
because we we haven't got the right
information to argue for or
against um and that so so what what
you're saying is we've made a decision
even though we're now told that decision
was wrong we're we're assessing against
a decision that we know to be wrong that
that's not making sense Jim so so again
where where do we stand on that position
because what what you've said to doesn't
make sense what what you need to do is
set aside the original decision that
that's already happened that is now a a
lawful planning permission you're
looking at a very limited or very narrow
remit here uh and that is whether the um
what is
proposed is acceptable and does that
have any additional impact on the um on
the the flooding situation and the
question or the answer to that is quite
clearly no it doesn't have any impact on
flooding if I may just just add to that
as well please in terms of the decision
that was taken on the original
application that was taken on the advice
that we had at the time from the the
local flood Authority so to say that
that decision was taken incorrectly
chair in my view is is not correct it
was properly taken based on the expert
evidence and information that the
council had at the time and which was
offered to members by officers on the
basis of the information that we had at
that time and following proper
consideration and consultation with the
experts the issue that is before members
this morning chair is as Jim says and as
he stated within the officer report that
the
llfa have accepted and note this section
73 application has no increase in terms
of flooding impact over above that which
has already been granted and therefore
chair as set out in in our report to
members and in the legal
advice you are
properly to afford no waight to any
objection or comment that the lrfa have
at this stage on that issue that is on
the That's the basis of our
recommendation to members chair thank
you just for clarity chair um and to
pick up Adrian's point the word
incorrect is what is used in the officer
report on page 46 it's not a word I'm
applying um so so just just for clarity
because Adrian is kind of implying that
I'm using the term incorrect I'm using
it from their own report thank you
councelor
Elliot thank you chair Adrian if you
could just indulge me uh I'm I'm not
comfortable with the flood part of it
and and I accept what you've explained
is is right that you know this this part
of the application is nothing to do with
that it's just but it's like stripping
out one tiny piece of information from
the whole
application and I'm not desperately
comfortable with making any decision on
it I read in 725 and this must be down
to the timelines it was done but it says
the llfa considered the current
hydraulic assessment and flood
compensation proposals aren't
satisfactory enough given the sufficient
confidence the RIS that flood risk isn't
increased can you just run me through
that to to to set in my mind because as
I say you can strip one piece of
information out we're not dealing with
the flood on this part of the
application that's what worries me
if I interpret the question correctly
share hope that'll help cancer Elliot if
not ask cancer Elliott to to come back
for clarification as necessary but as
I've just explained chair the the basis
of the original application that was
considered by members and approved was
based on the expert evidence that we had
at that time the expert evidence we
received from the llfa was that there
was no objection to the
application subsequent information as
impacted on that original consideration
and the LFA have the concerns which the
applicant has sought where they believed
appropriate to provide additional
information Etc and that has resulted in
their offer of the tank that um Phil
explained to you earlier is proposed now
by the applicant as an addition to seek
to um in part address the concerns that
the LFA raised
however in terms of the information that
we could properly ask for the advice
that we have is that if there is no
evidence that the current scheme is
going to impact on flooding any more
than the original and we've been advised
by the llfa themselves that is the case
there is actually no need to provide
additional information to support that
because there's no increased risk and as
Jim's advised that permission that's
granted is extent and can be implemented
so that's the basis of the lfa's
comments as I understand them they would
like more information the applicant has
said or we provided this information we
actually don't need to provide you with
any therefore whil you would like this
additional information there's no
requirement tell us to provide it so we
provided what we think is appropriate so
that's the situation that we have in
terms of the final outcome of this um we
have as officers sought clarification on
that point from the llfa and that's set
out in their
comments which we've underlined for for
emphasis on page 35 that the there is no
greater impact of this development on
that previously approved therefore on
that basis while it's offering
comment there is no basis for us as
officers to say to you as as members in
making a decision that you place any
weight on the concerns raised at this
point by the llfa even though they may
have concerns about about um the issue
of the press Brook and and how it reacts
to to flood events I hope that's helpful
chair in in setting up Cas the the
timelines as I understand thanks Adrian
that's exactly what I wanted explaining
and and I I understand you can't give us
any more information on it uh it it just
seems that you know with the information
given I'm struggling to make a decision
on it but but we are supposed to ignore
it basically that's what you're
saying the advice that we have um chair
is that yes there should be no weight
placed raised at this point by the lead
Local Food Authority in view of the
comments that they expressed on the
outline application based on the
information at that time thanks
Adrian Council
Armitage yeah thank you
chair it strikes me that all the way
along with this first planning
application and what we're asked to do
now the information that we've been
given have been flawed and uh you know
LFA uh have admitted this and uh we
voted on this to pass it because there
was they said there was no problem with
the flooding and if we look at the
actual uh problem with the flooding is
because there's no uh would you agree
there's no management of Smithy brook or
press uh Brook that actual uh Brook D
drained thousands of Acres from above
and if it was dug deep uh but cleaned
out to start with instead of all the
trees we won't be here uh looking about
flooding problems it should have been
drained it should have been done
properly to the correct spec and no one
seems to be wanting toh have any
anything to do with this
Brook and you know we're going to put
this uh would you agree that we putting
this flood tank in and as far as I can
see yeah it's all right put it in but
we've had some pretty heavy downpour and
uh we've been predicted we're going to
get more and uh is the tank big enough I
mean how big would it need to be to stop
this flood flooding problems on the site
pulled all the trees out which allows
them to the water to percolate slowly I
mean they were all pulled out and burnt
on site and uh as far as I can see this
flood tank won't make much difference at
all because it just fill up and
theoretically I would I be right in
saying it's due to empty at a slower
rate but he still going to put water
down into Smithy Brook which is already
gesture with Fallen trees and God knows
what when it should in the first
application have been cleaned out
completely and deepened to stop any
flood risk would you
agree I'm presuming chair that c
directed his questions at me I'll assist
as I can chair the maintenance of press
Brook is a matter for the management of
those um who have responsibility for
press and that's not something that we
as local plan responsibility for nor do
I believe the council has responsib May
well rest with the LFA or any riparian
owners that there are in terms of the
tank it is designed to ameliorate
any impact of flooding that there may be
during the Press BR any potential loss
of flood alleviation that the site may
have otherwise provided sh the advice we
have is that will it will make a
difference I'm not
a I'm not a hydrologist so I don't I
can't give chapter and verse on that but
to my mind the provision of tank storage
must have some positive impact on how
flood water would be managed as it comes
down press but because it provides some
storage that isn't there at the moment
so that that would be my view on that
but I'm not hydrologist we have reacted
at all stages chair to the expert advice
we received from the llfa the
environment agency and others and as
officers we presented that information
in good faith to members on which you
Bas your
decision I'd like to just draw your uh
attention to uh on page 35
4.14 any DDC Engineers have not
commented I mean surely after all the uh
flawed information that we were given in
the first instance it should have been
the engineers should have commented at
least said
something again shair we will have um
consulted the relevant bodies and so
their advice as we haven't received
anything we've reported that in good
faith to members chair the the primary
consulty on this the llfa did comment on
the original application as I've said we
presented that information their
comments and their no objection to the
application in good faith to members as
Jim explained earlier on chair that is
the background to this application
that's an extent position and in respect
of the current application as it
presents no greater impact on flooding
than that which has already
been approved and that is the basis of
the evidence that we've presented to
members which is backed up by the expert
legal advice chair that we've received
on that on that basis and that's the on
that basis that's the way that we've set
out our report to members in advising
you on this
application thank you are there any
further questions
thank you
Adrian I'll open the floor for debate
councilor
Li admit I'm very perturbed because uh
was involved with a similar application
of my own Ward a flood plane was built
on uh we were assured that things were
put into it was it was a pond this time
not a tank but it was supposedly to be
the water to be allowed to flow out
heavy rainfall to catch the water and it
to be allowed to flow out to slower raid
um the minute they took the top soil off
we were flooded um and now the
development is nearly finished about six
weeks ago we had that very very heavy
rain on the Sunday um our neighbors were
flooded they were away on holiday um I
followed the course back onto the
development and there was nothing in
that pond so it wasn't holding anything
it was just going straight through as it
always had only twice as fast um so I'm
very concern that that won't
work um that's that's my worry I know
we're not supposed to be talking about
flooding Etc but I think it is
relevant any further
comment councilor Hancock then counselor
bar thank you chair um I I agree with
everything Heather's saying here um I I
totally respect what the officers are
saying and and I know um what Adrian
says is 100% correct that they give us
the information in good faith and and
the reality is when the previous
planning plan when it came before
planning before that information was
also given in good faith the problem is
that information has been proved to be
wrong um the the legal advice which is
is stated in
7.27 is is less clear than is being
presented to us because it does say that
uh uh weight is a matter entirely for
the decision maker and provide and that
provided the decision maker properly
takes into account all relevant matters
and does not take account of irrelevant
matters
no court will inter will interfere with
any decision well the reality is it is a
relevant matter because we wouldn't have
spent four pages of five pages of this
report discussing it um yes we're being
told there's no further there's no
greater flood rest than there was
previously but the LF llfa are actually
basing that on the fact that or appear
to with the way it's worded in here
based on the fact that they have raise
concerns and those concerns were were
not taken into account because they
weren't present when that decision was
made
um my honest opinion is I can't I can't
go with this uh with this recommendation
I don't think there's enough evidence
for us to go against it but I do think
we've got to defer and have proper
reports in front of us so that we can
make a proper informed decision um so so
yeah I I can't comment any further than
that because there's there's not enough
for us to go on
chair there's lots of comments about
reports Etc so I'd like people to
actually consider page 47
7.27 uh on and it goes on about the
flood risk and the bottom part of it is
further it is advised that in the event
that the llfa cannot identify how and to
what extent the section 73 application
increases the risk of flooding over and
above that which already exists arising
from the permissions already granted the
the decision maker can and should place
no weight on any objection made by the
lffa council reminds the council that
wait is the matter entirely for the
decision maker and that provided that
the decision maker properly takes into
account all relevant matters and does
not take account of irrelevant matters
no court will interfere with any
decision as to the weight given to a
particular matter unless there has been
perver perversity
however to give weight to an objection
which is irrelevant to The Works being
proposed would be
perverse and I think that's something we
really need to consider because this
application is an
amendment and I shared people's issues
about flooding but that is not what is
before us today thank
you oh councilor Barker sorry I
preempted you apologies it's all right
now Without You rounding up spee sorry
no no that was me having myself that's
all right uh it's just difficult is it
this one I'm struggling with it same as
uh one or two have already said and uh I
wasn't involved in original decision uh
I know it's been controversial and I
know we're looking at the the monor
Amendments because it's already been
approved uh but having read the report
and listened to what folks have got to
say and and other
counselors uh I'm
to to put me name to it because if in
the future there's flooding on this side
for the new housers or on wind year Ro I
I'd feel guilty about that so I tend to
support what council hanock said uh
there there is a lot of stuff in here
that that's just vague I mean there's a
lot of them initial llfa and all that
that are not happy with it is and I
accept what you've just said Diane you
know that that paragraph doesn't make it
clear we're only considering this but
I'm still struggling to put my name to
that because I've just come to it today
so that that's where I am and and if
there's if there is a a compromise
somewhere along line like Council anot
just said then I I'll consider that so
I'm still undecided what way to vote to
be
honest okay are there any further
comments councelor
pal
[Music]
we're faced with very difficult set of
circumstances aren't
we but I have to say that we have no
choice what is actually before us um is
not controversial everything that's gone
before has been but we've got to just
look at as this committee's
responsibility is to um not come
consider what's happened in the past but
only to consider what's happening now
and as we have been told more than once
it makes no material difference or no
additional risk it's unfortunate um and
uh but but as I say I don't think we
have any choice thank you chair thank
you any other comment I'll put it over
to a motion
anyone excuse me CH just before you do
that would it be helpful if I just
reminded members um about the
arrangements disregard motions yes thank
you Alan okay thank you chair uh please
bear in mind members that a motion must
be moved and seconded before a vote is
taken if an amendment to a motion is
moved and seconded then that Amendment
will be voted on
first if a motion is to be moved which
goes against officer
recommendations then the member who has
moved the motion must give the reasons
for do doing
so the reasons for moving a motion
against officer recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by the evidence as
necessary if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls or in other words
it is not passed that doesn't mean that
the recommendations are automatically
approved rather you will need to take a
positive decision through a further
Motion in favor of the recommendations
or the course of action this will need
to be approved by the committee through
another vote thank you
chair thank you well I will actually
support the office's recommendation and
that is my motion put forward that we
vote on that I'll second that chair
thank
you and I will have a roll call thank
you thank you chair members if you
kindly um indicate for against or
abstain Council Armitage again
against councelor
Barker councelor
KF
abstain councelor Cooper
AB councelor Elliot abstain councelor
Hancock
against counc
hson
abstain Council lied
abstain councilor powerwell
councilor
Rouse
against and councilor
Ruff so chair with two votes for three
against and six abstentions the motion
Falls councilor Hancock chair can I move
that we defer while we have proper so
that we can have proper information to
make a decision on in the future because
what what we have got
it's telling us there's no greater flood
risk but we genuinely don't know what
the flood risk is and I think we do need
to have that information to make a
proper decision so so that that's my
motion to to counsel if someone's happy
to uh to second that councelor Al has
just second it those chair if I may just
just before members um take a take a
vote on that if members were minded to
defer the
application then we would need to be
given clear advis as officers what the
deferral was based on and what
additional information you are looking
for because we would need to be specific
in respect of any request we go back to
the applicant on for that information
and I just asked members
to recall what I said earlier on that
the applicant has responded to a certain
level of additional information being
provided but they've taken view
that they have provided more than they
believe is necessary and have sought to
on the basis of that provide the the
tank that's part of the
consideration that's before you and also
chair in terms of the the advice that um
we've been given again ask members to to
note that and the allowance that we have
for seeking additional advice bearing in
mind the llfa have themselves said that
The Proposal before you is not going to
increase the level of flooding over and
above what is extent and can be
constructed so if members are minded to
defer the application we need to be very
clear what additional information is
given and then we would seek that from
from the applicant and await in a
response thank you chair councilor hanok
thank you chair for for clarification
from my perspective and and obviously it
will be up to councel he's happy
seconding that the information that we
have is not consistent we're asking for
consistency the llfa are saying that
there is no further based on on what
they're saying but but that's not
actually consistent with with the
previous ex extent uh permission it's
that what we've got just is is a mess
and we're be we've been put in a catch
22 situation of being asked to approve
something that we've been told the
original information is incorrect we
need direct information we're asking
we're we're giving a decision based on
facts we haven't got
facts so so we need Clarity in order to
put a proper a proper discussion forward
and to be perfectly honest I'd like it
minuted the officer shouldn't be putting
us in this position um whether that's
our officers or other people's so that
that hopefully gives the clarity we need
to know what the flood risk is because
it's being referred to in this report
we're not introducing it from nowhere um
but but we're being told to compare to
information information which it
explicitly says is incorrect so we want
correct information
please does that information take us
back to the original application then
Adrian because that's not what's before
us because historically it's been
passed yes chair I'm not seeking to put
members in a difficult position and my
apologies if it's taken that way all I'm
seeking to Asain from Members is if the
committee is minded to defer the
application what other information
members are see speaking and I'm also
trying to frame that in the on the the
basis of the advice that we have from
legal colleagues and from the
information we've already received from
the applicant I can see that Rich has
got his hand up as well CH he might be
able to to add something further to what
I've just
said
okay who who would had sorry Adrian who
had the hand up Richard oh sorry Richard
thank you oh I can see you now
thank you yeah I I um just to of add to
um to what Adrian has uh has said there
um that clearly if there is a request
for some additional information then
that information must be appropriate for
this particular type of application um
not uh information that um should have
been required previously last year when
the last application was determined and
and that is what's
I think that there is a well I think
there's an absence from the debate that
I've heard so far that the request for
information isn't um information that is
relative to this current application it
is only relevant to to the um
application that we have previously had
now I don't particularly want at this
point in time to go back to that
application because I think we need to
concentrate on what this particular
application is about and just to say
that um yeah it is quite clear from the
legal advice that has been received what
the scope of this type of application is
and I think that
you I think everyone around the screen
everyone in the room would have some um
empathy for the the situation that we
have here and and understands the issue
of flood risk however the the legal
framework for this type of application
does not allow this issue to be given
weight because there is no difference
between this issue um this application
on this issue and the and the approved
one and to make a uh a positive decision
in relation to this application isn't to
throw away that empathy or sympathy that
um that uh decision makers counselors
that uh officers have in relation to
this it is to recognize the fact that
this is not something that can be taken
on board as part of this
application
thank you councelor hok do you want to
be more specific on what you would
require I I'm not sure that I can be any
more specific I mean I mean ultimately
we we're faced with an application here
that has got information that is
different to to what was put before
Council previously and and we've got
conflicting information in it and the
llfa are giving us one course of advice
saying that that that it's it's it's not
an increased flood risk but that they've
got concerns over it so so it's there so
we we need whether we need clarification
from them whether we need this report I
don't know really that's for officers to
determine what they're doing here though
is saying that there's no greater risk
or we're not sure what we're comparing
to so with with respect to Richard this
is the report that your team has given
us your team have given us contradictory
information we cannot make a decision on
this in my opinion we we've already
voted down to follow your
recommendations we're saying we haven't
got enough information to actually put
put a counter to it to reject it we we
need something to go on and we haven't
got it
here councilor
Armitage I'd just like to add this point
we're voting today on a tank uh which is
supposed to be stopping all the flood uh
uh flooding that's going on now this
tank will ultim L drain at a lower rate
into the into the brook and that's the
problem it's going to drain into the
brook the Tank's going to drain into the
brook which will cause more
flooding and that's my point it's
nothing you know we're voting on the on
this uh tank which is supposed to be
stopping all this flood risk well it's
just going to exasperate the the whole
problem because it's going into rest
Brook which is already choked and should
have been cleaned out in the first place
and that's my
point can I can I respond to that chair
yes certainly um yeah just to just to
clarify to go back to where we to the
start of the officer presentation as to
what this application is about this is
about the the alterations to the layout
of the site and positioning of houses
that's the reason why the application
has come in the applicants have added
this tank really as a a gesture of
Goodwill to what this um this
application um to open and above what
the application is about and
uh
that whether that tank is big enough to
solve by a problem that uh members
perceive as as existing is uh is the
side issue to what this Happ
is is really
about but it's on the table as part of
the application this
tank so it's got to be
considered I hear what's what's what
you're saying and the reason why uh but
as I
say they they've added that tank to
address an issue that was has has been
raised not uh because they have needed
to do that as part of the application
that they want to see um to see approve
and I think it would be a bit uh
disingenuous to um hold the tank against
them um when that is something that they
have added in as a as a almost like a
Goodwill gesture to um uh to the
concerns that have been raised during
the course of
application yes they've obviously uh
taken note of what's been said and
what's been happening on site uh with
the ripping out of all the trees and
undergrowth which would have sufficed to
slow the flow down and they're going to
put this tank in to try and alleviate
the problem but the Tank's going to run
in and cause more problems because it'll
go in at a faster rate than it would
have done if it had been percolating
through the trees and
everything come in there ch um Armitage
the the tanks taking the water from the
from the brook not firstly that that's
the purpose of
it no councelor Hancock thank you chair
I I mean to to return to what Richard
was saying which which I I do fully
agree with I think we are perhaps
sidetracking a little bit because the
the tank that the the application that's
in front of us is to to vary the the
design the problem that we have or that
I'm pering is we don't know the impact
whether it's got an impact on the
flooding or not because we are
explicitly told in this report that the
previous representation was incorrect so
on that basis and that basis alone is
why I'm saying it should be deferred
because we we're we've got an
application to vary something but we're
varying it from something that we don't
know what the impact was to begin with
because it was
incorrect so that is is why the the
Motions on the table to to actually
defer so we can have proper information
and come back with a proper decision
whichever way that that
is I think we're going round and round
in circles here so can we move this uh
David has put in a motion to defer coun
second so just to be clear chair it's to
defer on the basis that uh before they
can take a decision to uh vary the
application members will need additional
information as to what the flooding
impact of the variation would be is that
the essence of
it sorry councelor hanock I can't hear
you I apologies I don't put my
microphone on Alan no it's it's to
clarify what the flooding risk is
because we're told in the report that
the previous data was incorrect well
knowing that it's incorrect we can't
then make a decision as to whether
there's an increased flooding risk from
this or
not okay
so that that's irrelevant because it has
been passed but have to draw this to a
close I think we just need to have a
vote on this deferment so I'm going to
ask for a roll
call thank you chair as before if you
could um kindly just say for against or
abstain councelor Armitage for Council
barer councelor cluf four councelor
Cooper councelor Elliot
AB councelor Hancock four counc
harson
AB councel
liot
lone Council
Powell
Council
Rouse
for Council buff
against six votes for two against with
three abstentions the motion is carried
to
defer thank you ladies and gentlemen I
think we're due for a few minutes
break there is uh tea and coffee I
believe in the members room there's also
some chalkies here if you so wish to
have some extra
boost would 11:00 be um suitable chair I
think so uh when are the next speakers
du uh they'll be arriving round about 11
o'clock I'll actually check whether
anyone's arrived yet be in for that
thank you yeah that's great thank you
very much
everybody
ladies and gentlemen back to The Fray is
everyone back I've got an empty chair oh
that's Andrews right
okay you're still
here so the third application this
morning is
[Music]
n2100
885l at pilsley and I'll ask the
officers to start their
presentation thank you chair may I first
confirmed that we've received one L
representation which raises private land
ownership issues that are not material
to the determination of this
application in terms of detailing uh
this is a full application for the
demolition of the existing social club
building and the erection of free
sustainable detached self-build homes
including Associated alterations to the
existing access at pilsley miners
welfare RIT Street lower pilsley members
of planning committee attended a virtual
site visit yesterday where we saw a
range of photos of the site
officers considered that the proposal
would be in keeping with the character
and appearance of the mixed Street Scene
there would be no detrimental impacts
upon neighboring Properties or land uses
nor would the scheme lead to any adverse
impacts upon highway safety matters
relating to ecology drainage and land
contamination can be addressed through
conditions and the proposed development
is considered to represent positive
Redevelopment of the site which cords
with both local and National planning
policy could have the next slide
please thank you so this this first plan
illustrates the site shaded in Orange to
the center of the screen the site is
located to the east of ret street
Falling outside but adjacent to the
settlement development limit of pilsley
the site is bounded by Residential
Properties to the north and Northwest
and the recreation ground to the east
and south next slide
please thank you the red line denotes
the parcel of land subject to the
application and the blue line identifies
the applicant's land
ownership thank
you this slide shows the block plan of
the existing site the man's welfare
building will be demolished as part of
The Proposal that can be see now thank
you
here we have the proposed block plan the
free dwellings will be positioned in a
linear row fronting onto the highway
which is broadly in line with the
existing buildings that extend to the
north of the
site the existing access point will be
utilized although widen to Accord to
Highway standards each property would be
served by three parking spaces and a
private Garden to the
rear thank
you so the next two slides we'll show
the existing and proposed Street
elevations thank
you again the Second Street
elevation thank you so these next three
slides illustrate the elevation of floor
plans the three dwellings this is plot
one and it will be the smallest of the
three plots and comprised of a
two-bedroom dwelling finished in PE
colored render with gray clad in the
next one pleas please so here we've got
the second plot this features a free
bedroom detached dwelling finished in
Sky colored render and violet blue
clading and the next one
please thank you so this is the third
and largest of the plots and it features
a free bedroom dwelling finishing pretty
white colored render with gray brown
clading thank
you thank you so this slide shows a plan
taken from the ball risk assessment
which was undertaken by labos sport
pink Arc identifies the ball trajectory
radius as you can see from the plan um
the corner of plot one and plot two do
fall within the ball strike area these
areas shall be fenced off and can be
controlled by way of
condition have the next slide
please thank you so the next few slides
are key photos taken from the committee
site visit which members attended
yesterday I've included these as a
refresher for members um so this first
photo this is taken from the adjacent
Recreation ground um to the South
looking back towards the uh site
to the north and this shows the social
club building which has been close since
2012 have next one
please thank you so here we've got a
photo of the existing Social Club this
is taken from the cricket field to the
east so looking in the Westerly
Direction have the next one please
thank you so this photo is taken from
Highway ret Street looking back towards
um the the social club as you can see
it's in an elevated position above the
highway the existing um stone wall and
hone hedge above will be retained as
part of the scheme have the next slide
please thank you again this photo is
taken from the highway along roofit
Street as you can see on the left hand
side you've got the access point this
will be
utilized thank
you thank you so this photo is taken
within the site um straight ahead is the
access track which leads to two favor
properties just to the right of the
photo and on your left hand side and in
the background you have got the
recreational ground and the cricket and
football pitches for field have the next
slide
please thank you so this photo is taken
from the same spot but to the right hand
side and this shows uh the proposed
location for the internal shared
driveway which will extend along the
front of the three dwellings and each
dwelling will be served by three um
designated parking spots one of the
three parking spots will be a disabled
parking space and will'll feature an
electric charging Point have the next
slide
please thank you uh so this photo shows
uh the the remaining part of the track
as you can see it leads to the property
in in the background on the left hand
side you'll see um a fenced off grass
area this area doesn't form part of the
development and will remain as it is
currently have the next slide
please thank you so this last photo is
taken um from the car part to the south
of the site and it just shows an overall
view of of the proposed development
area the next one please think it may be
the last one y brilliant thank you that
concludes the presentation thank you
chair thank
you he we can move on to the speakers
and just so you're aware the speakers
I'm sure councelor Cooper is that you
have three minutes when you're called
councelor
Cooper
thank you chair and members uh obviously
this this application uh Falls within my
ward uh and obviously the links to ply
Cricket ply and Clay Cross Cricket Club
I have have made it essential that I uh
don't take any part in the debate today
um I call this application in for three
main reasons one the ball stop net two
the car parking issues and three public
interest thankfully uh due to excellent
work by the planning officer and the
diligence of the darbishire cricket
foundation and the
ECB uh and particularly the sport
England the report is now full and
comprehensive and allows members to make
an educated decision on all the facts
before them uh despite my concerns about
this application from a public safety
point of view I've always been very
supportive of the site being developed
and the scheme before you today I
believe will be good for the
area uh as a Cricket Club we do have
some slight concerns uh about this but
John worthy who a secretary uh will be
speaking shortly um and he may be
looking to address some of these issues
and with some additional
conditions with reference to the ball
stop net uh Lao sport have conducted a
further assessment from the first one
following concerns by sport England this
has now been accepted by all parties and
hopefully will give the protection
required uh to the new
developments with reference to car
parking problems on site uh despite
being very disappo disappointed that
from the previous application several
years ago the 27 spaces promised on the
on the last application have been
removed from the current
application as a report states there was
there's no legal requirement or
agreement for the for any new developer
to provide any parking at the sports
ground uh and obviously um Mr Mr have
decided not to not to uh afford that as
part of this application which is
obviously entirely up to them and and I
for one wouldn't say they were right or
wrong on that but the the sports ground
do have parking issues uh regular
problems on rer street outside
um the new Pavilion Etc and and
continuing along and up the hill this
particularly obviously when when there's
any sports games taking place and this
will continue remain thank you and this
will continue until a solution is found
to finish i' just like to say that the
Cricket Club have been in existence
since 1886 and it's important that we
have a good relationship with the
developers moving forward it's likely
that both the Cricket Club and the
development will be in existence long
after both par par is discussing this
application today are no longer no sorry
are no longer here thank you thank you
are there any questions councilor Elliot
then councilor armage Council Barker
thank you
chair Andrew could you just explain to
me I'm looking at the the one mentions
27 the removal of 27 spaces and at the
bottom of the page it says the South
site the Bowling Green with 31 spaces is
that the same place
no on the previous
application uh on the where the houses
are going to be built now um along the
entrance and along the
frontage in the part that's not actually
forming part of this application there
was 27 additional spaces to the 31 right
when we when the the welfare was in
existence there were probably 70 to 80
car parking spaces which were used for
Sports and the the actual Club itself so
will that exacerbate the issue on rert
Street the situation Remains the Same if
there had been additional car parking
spaces then of course it would have
helped the
situation but as as there's no legal
requirement for the developers to do
that it's it is how it is it is how it
is CH I've got another question if
that's all right and I read about the 16
M High B to stop the balls going over
was that an advisory or a mandatory from
the sport England once again going back
to the the application
previously the ball stop now then would
have been right at the front of the site
on the on the edge of the the boundary
the part that ABS the cricket field so
it would have been much closer because
they've
taken um that area and the road out of
that and they've as you saw from the
plans the ball strike net now goes
across the three well two of the three
Gardens for the new new development so
it's much it's much further back than
what it was so it it lessens the impact
has it shorten the boundary lengthen the
boundary it's not Chang the boundary
from the cricket side but it's shortened
or it's lengthened
the the hit from a cricket ball to where
the property boundar is going to be so
not the not the boundary of the cricket
field but the boundary of the three
properties so essentially
safer well should be Lao sport have said
that's that's their assessment sport
England have accepted it and as a
Cricket Club we were concerned about
Public Safety if if if all parties are
happy with a two meter fence then we
have no way to um argue against that
it's been done it's been done properly
yeah if the safety has been met I'm with
that as well thank you p
armage uh
uh Council Elliot has asked the question
that I was going to ask about the ball
safety uh I presume we've got somebody
who can smack it that
far uh good
question I don't know the answer to that
you know that's that's a that's a $24
million question or whatever it you say
you know I mean I'm pretty sure that in
in past um I could have H it a fair way
but I don't play anymore so I'll turn
myself out of that equation okay thank
you councilor
Barker lovely thank you thank you
counselor and next speaker is John
worthy and I believe he's joining us by
Zoom uh thank you can you hear me okay I
can yes can't see you but we can hear
you okay um so John representing pills
and Clay Cross Cricket Club um and first
of all the Cricket Club supports the
Redevelopment of the welfare site we
we've seen over the years that it's
become derel and what was once a key
part of the community is no is no longer
so we do support the
Redevelopment we want to make sure the
development is carried out in such a way
that it's for the long-term benefit of
the developer and the Cricket Club and
as Andrew mentioned the cricket club's
been on site for over 130 years
we acknowledged sport England's comments
about the site and the height of the
safety
fence um on previous applications the
safety fence was on the boundary Edge
and was hence a lot higher than is now
proposed um so of was originally about
16 meters
High um and that during priv games there
is no access to parts of plot one and
plot two that remain within the ball
stri
Zone um just adding to a question that
was asked of Andrew do we have anybody
that can hit a ball that far in previous
years we have employed a professional
cricketer um who could certainly hit the
ball that far and if you follow Cricket
at all you know we are aware that BS do
get hit further and further because of
the development of cricket bats and so
on so safety is Paramount
Tois um and that
anyone and that during cricket games
anyone entering the strike zone outside
of plots 1 two and three do so at their
own risk because there is a sizable
space
now between between where the new safety
fence is proposed and where the previous
safety fence it was
proposed
um we would ask that um currently there
is no arrangement for the retrieval of
CR balls from the the area
between the boundary line and the new
fence so that space that was is now
owned by the
developer um and there needs to be an
acceptable Arrangement between the
developer and the Cricket Club for the
retrieval of cricket balls during match
days and
games if the saf defense was where it
was previously proposed that wouldn't
have been an issue because it wouldn't
have got in there but with the safet def
fence being pushed back there is now
that uh that situation that we need to
address 30 seconds for
main um and that's it from uh the
cricket club's perspective thank you for
your
time thank you are there any
questions no thank you Mr worthy thank
you our next speaker is Joan Hooper Oh
no you're going first okay so it's Gary
hoop
yes just press the red one and then you
three minutes when you're ready
yeah good morning chairs and members of
the committee I would like to start by
making the following points in respect
of our proposal I'll sorry about that
our application proposal is on a
Brownfield land the miners welfare
social club building has
been uh on use since it closed in April
2012 the building in the site was
falling into disrepair and attracted
significant antisocial Behavior prior to
our purchase we fence a site off which
we had to do due to the needs to ensure
safety preventing access to the building
and trespass this was a condition of our
public liability insurance
requirements as responsible land owners
we are entitled to fence off land that
we have we own and we have done so for
legitimate reasons therefore the
application before you does not propose
car parking on our land for parties
using the recreation ground Cricket Club
or any other related
use once the safety once the was safely
fenced off antisocial Behavior seized
and local residents were
delighted it is ConEd that concerns in
respect of increased parking need to be
needs to be addressed by others and not
private land owners such as ourselves
and the officer report paragraphs 8.50
and
8.52 make it clear that there is no
requirement to provide for public
parking whilst we're sympathetic to the
issue parking issues raised parking
Provisions exist within the immediate
vicinities of the recreation ground and
elsewhere in the village indeed the
parish Council have recently passed a
motion to resurface one of these car
Parks access through our land is
maintained to the recreation ground as
can be seen on the propos site layout
plan and it was drawing number PMW
i-102
revo2 I'd like to thank you that's it
thank you are there any
questions no thank you if you'd like to
take your
seat
are you going to speak
yeah three minutes when you're
ready good morning chair members of the
committee following on from what my
husband said I'd like to add our
application proposes the Redevelopment
of what is now a very dilapidated site
and the erection of three detached
self-built homes with associated off
street parking and alterations to the
existing access the principle of our
development is supported by national and
local planning policy long established
by previous planning permissions our
proposal will be highly sustainable
maximizing the use of high level energy
saving solar panels renewable energy
rainwater harvesting water saving
technology high quality installation
double glazing and car charging points
the build standard will be very high and
of style proportions and materials
sympathetic and in keeping with the
immediate environs internal design has
been carefully considered in terms of
functionality and future proofing for
our lifetime occupation our proposal is
well supported by our immediate
neighbors and local community as shown
by the support letters and it's
noteworthy that the scheme has the
support of officers who understand the
benefits our scheme will bring it will
make a positive contribution to the
local economy as we intend to lose use
local suppliers and trades such as
electrician or plaster orbe the majority
of the build will be completed and
project managed by ourselves
environmentally there will be
significant benefits improving
biodiversity by Greening the site using
native species and hedging as for the
landscape plan ecological enhancements
will be achieved by providing suitable
habitats through selective planting
including fruit trees and the provision
of bat and bird boxes our proposed
scheme will create high quality homes
deliver sign ific betterment for
neighboring houses and the recreation
field providing natural surveillance on
an area that has attracted antisocial
Behavior there are no objections from
statutary consules some of whom we have
worked very closely with due to the site
location the objections raised relate
slow solely to matters not pertinent to
the planning case and fall outside the
jurisdiction of planning considerations
or have been addressed through the
planning process and proposed conditions
overall we've lived in P for 34 years we
self-built our current house and we're
very committed to our houses being an
Exemplar self-built scheme that we hope
will act as a catalyst encouraging
others to self-build it will allow us to
remain part of the community that we
chose to live in and wish to remain in
in the knowledge that we've got the
support of the local community 30
seconds remain we respectfully asked
members to Grant permission for our
self- build scheme which is supported by
the community and will make a long-term
positive contribution to the site and
importantly adjacent neighbors the
immediate locality and to our village
community who believe that this proposal
is the right scheme for our neglected
site thank you thank you are there any
questions oh sorry
councelor can I just ask is there a
reason why you've got your three
properties different
colors yeah can can I
no no you can't answer them wrong there
is a good reason for
it oh
yeah it's to do with future proofing
really that there's sort of evidence
that backs up that different colors are
easier to
identify houses if people have Dementia
or you
know things like that okay I know it's
it it it perhaps doesn't sound as
serious now but perhaps when if old
people are living in them and they're
getting a bit confused about where or
what it's more easily identified with
different colors and that was the reason
it it we didn't just sort of you know
please excuse me I've got Croy voice um
we're talking back to the ball strike
next yeah um obviously it is what it is
with that can you guarantee that if
those Cricket balls on Match days go
into your say Garden or property will
they be able to treeve those back we've
already offered um but we haven't had a
response to we offered I think via the
parish council or trustees that we will
collect we'll collect any balls that
come over in any of the areas and we'll
give them back to wherever they want us
whether they want us to leave it at the
local Pavilion that's there take them to
somebody's house or just save them to
another day and we have got evidence of
that we've got an email that we sent
offering that but unfortunately we've
not had a
response so we don't want to keep
anybody's Cricket balls we will make
sure that they get them back yeah thank
you any further questions no thank you
for that thank
[Music]
you are there any questions for the
officers councilor
Barker uh thank you can can you put the
slide back up uh with the were ball
strike radius please can you put that
one up I just want some clarity around
that and I think you said that is it
possible to do
that I weren't sure exactly what we want
with that one uh that's it is that is
that visible now yeah yeah thanks Adrian
yeah just just some advice there there's
a radius
obviously
there's a better one Adrian with the red
line on I think that's the one I we're
looking
at I think that one had have done it
there that's the one okay yeah that's it
yeah yeah so all that in green then
belongs the applicant is that right all
that in green so the cricket pitch is
beyond yeah that where you're showing
now so what what happens if the ball
goes in that bit that that that bit in
front of the radius I can see where
you're putting a fence that's clear
that's where you're putting your fence
is it where the where the radius is that
that's on edge of their
Gardens what you doing with that what
what's happening with that other bit
can do anything
it excuse me these are questions to the
officers you can't speak I I just I just
wonder from officer's perspective how is
how is that going to
work um thank you counselor um yeah the
area the the green area will remain as
it is so there's no development proposed
to this area um and and it won't
actually be utilized I
believe so can the applicant then fence
that off and and so nobody can go in it
is the the area is already fenced off
and Will it's yeah okay I can ask the
other in the debate I can clarify that
bet and you also said it can be
controlled by condition what did you
mean by that yes so the the two areas
that are shown within the plot one and
plot two you can see the corners where a
slightly lighter green so those two
areas will be um fenced off and there
will be a condition if approved attached
to the decision that ensures that these
two areas are not used when a game is
being under
taken okay any further questions for the
officers no thank you Emily in which
case I open the floor for
debate Council Barker then Council
Elliot Ju Ju Just just on that really
from where I'm picking up I don't I'm I
like the development the Cricket Club
say they in favor of it the club wants
knocking down the we which used to be a
good welfare one time uh I have used it
on several occasions uh but it it's like
the development's fine I think all I'm
picking up from the uh from what's been
said was it Mr worthy it's that rich
Ball retrieval in that no man's land if
you like well it's not no man's it's
theirs but uh if the ball goes in that
in a game can they get it back during
the game is it be my question and
because that's that seems to be the only
issue that the cricket club's got as far
as I can see it'll be nice to have
parking but that's your discretion
that's fine it's covered it's that ball
retrieval seems to be the issue for me
and whether or not we can do anything
about that put it in a condition or
something like that and thank you
counselor um that's actually not
something that we could control VI under
planning or via a condition it would be
a matter between the two parties so it
would be a civil legal matter um so
unfortunately it's not something we
could control under
planning if I just add to that chair if
I may
the fence that em explained is the um
the ball strip fencing would be a 2
meter high
fence the other areas could otherwise be
cont fenced off by the applicant should
they so wish the only way that the
committee could control that is if they
were to remove other committed rights to
erect fencing Etc within those other
areas perhaps over one meter in height
which would then allow access during a
cricket game to those other areas that's
the only other way as 's pointed out
that otherwise it would be purely and
simply a legal matter between the
parties and allowing access otherwise
into those areas but if members were
particularly minded about that
it could be conditioned that any fencing
for example erected outside the B within
the ball strike area didn't exceed
perhaps one meter in height it would
allow some fencing to take place but not
then restrict any retrieval of balls
during a
game
that's thank you chair Adrian's just
touched on it really uh I was going to
say is it possible we could condition a
gate so instead of clambering over and
you know struggling to retrieve those
balls during a match if it was gated
they could and it was unlocked I mean it
sounds very much like the Cricket Club
and Mr M have got a good relationship
and the balls would be retrieved anyway
but I know on a match day probably
people had like to retrieve the ball
there and then and and continue playing
with the ball that they've been playing
with
um I would I would like to see that
happen and my
my advice to to members rather than
requiring a gate that should be open
because that my view is that would um
create some enforceability issues it
would mean what happens if it were
locked would you um be requiring
presence on site during all games to
ensure it wasn't for example my
suggestion if you are concerned about
that and and otherwise you are content
with the development that whilst
allowing the the two me Bard strike
fencing to be in place as a two mid High
fencing you otherwise restrict permitted
rights within that area to fencing no
higher than one meter in height that
would be my my suggestion chair thanks
Adan that's useful AB advice but by and
large I'm quite happy with the
application you know I did ask about the
safety issue that seems to have been met
uh you've just given us added added
information fine with it thanks
just just in terms of that sh there's no
condition to that effect currently
proposed thank you councilor
Armitage thank you uh it's really with
the respect to the the fence uh these
fences are expensive and I take it that
the uh developer are they're going
to well they're going to deal with the
cost of it rather than the Cricket
Club and the other thing was uh I think
it is a bit not quite high enough
bearing in mind that as uh uh councelor
Cooper says and his colleague they do
get overseas players who can hit these
balls and a long long way and uh I would
have hoped it could have been uh made a
little bigger uh maybe uh 3 meters but
that could be conditioned and as regards
the fence uh
access uh I think there are rules and
regulations that say you can't change
the balls during a match I mean there
are all these rules uh which come into
effect uh I'm not uh up to date with it
all but I am up to date with the cost of
a cricket ball under 35 each I think at
the moment and uh you know they do need
retrieving and if there was a gate there
it could be locked and the key could be
one with the owner and one with the uh
with the Cricket Club so that the balls
could be retrieved during a match so
they wouldn't receive any penalties from
the governing bodies which they seem to
be able to put on but that's just my
thought on it thank you can can I just
come back to just on a couple those
points and Emily perhaps um add anything
if she thinks appropriate chair the
first of all the the 2 meter high fence
has been proposed by through proper
consideration by labo sport
consideration by sport England and the
other bodies chair so I think it would
be um certainly my view that it would be
inappropriate to require that to be of a
of a taller height than the 2 MERS and
in the location propos chair um just um
just considering the the issue that's
been raised a couple times about access
during
in during games and I'm not and a
condition could be to the effect that
the fencing is gated affording access
during cricket games I think that would
be dis precise and can be enforced it
just is something that if it weren't
complied with May create some problems
in terms of enforceability but I don't
that could I wouldn't wish to rule that
on wouldn't wish to rule that out on
reflection if members felt but
restriction on the fencing in terms of
its height was perhaps inappropriate but
to provide gated and Open Access during
the the games of cricket being played on
site and just one other point on
conditions chair just it's normally in
our recommendation that the
recommendation does allow provision that
any minor word changing is delegated to
myself ask if are minded to Grant
permission in this case that's also
afforded to officers as
necessary thank you are there any
further questions no I'll open the floor
for debate councilor
Elliot sorry chair I was I
was I was just going to propose we go
with officer recommendation I was ahead
of
myself okay Council
Parker can we add that extra condition
then Me Def yeah happy for that is is
would that be acceptable to put that
condition in so we're looking at
everything else just that the one me
defense okay councelor Hancock thank you
chair um I mean firstly I will say it's
actually lovely to have some developers
who are so conscious of the community
because absolute credit to to the
gentleman May there um the the only B
I'll be honest I know absolutely zil
about sport I'm the world's worst person
on on this but but I do have neighbors
with children who knock and kick balls
Over the Garden Edge all of the time um
and to be
honest I I mean I just tell them to come
around and get whatever but but to me it
it it concerns me that we would put
conditions on somebody's private land
that they need to give someone else
access to it um I mean we have seen how
how how amiable this this lady and
gentlemen are obviously ownership will
change over time anyway I think what
what agent says is quite right about
enforceability um but but to me it
scares me going down that route if I'm
honest in actually putting stipulations
on what someone can and can't do with
their own boundary fence and and and
allowing access so I I fully support the
application but I I genuinely couldn't
support that that as an extra
condition okay gentlemen where are we at
chair just just on that point then we
would need prior to any any vote if
members are minded to um support the
recommendation just have clarification
on that issue of the fening ETC if there
is no condition placed on any approval
then permitted rights would extend up to
two meters in height in other cases so
that would be the other um potential
outcome um and of course whilst the the
current applicants are as you've heard
today working closely with their
neighbors that isn't something that we
as officers could guarantee into the
future should the properties be sold on
or otherwise disposed of down the
line Jim Jim chair is is just waving at
you so he may be able to to add
something CH chair I'm quite happy sorry
Nigel I'm quite happy to go with what
Adrian's saying and just go with it as
it stands
okay you still second
it okay I believe Jim wants to have a
quick words from
legal I was just going to say that I
would have concerns about the um the
legality of a clause of that nature but
since it's now being withdrawn that's I
don't need to to go into that in any
more detail thank you okay Council
Barker I've heard what's been said and I
accept that and and I take good faith
and hopefully you can work with the
Cricket Club I think I think the main
concern is and You' said you'll you'll
give them the balls back but it's during
the game is the issue and if you can do
some sort of compromise with the Cricket
Club I'm sure we'd all appreciate that I
think you you are working together as
best as you can so if just an assurance
on that and I'll go with what's been
proposed okay no I don't think so but
okay we've got a motion on the table to
and seconded to actually sorry chair
just to be clear then the motion is to
approve officer recommendations with the
final wording of the delegations um to
be um um delegated to the development
manager Planning Development manager yes
right thanks thank you I'm going to have
a roll call for that just just to be
absolutely clear that's as as set out
share without any further conditions or
additions yes yeah thank you
okay thank you I'll commence the B call
Council Armitage for councilor Barker
councelor kff for councelor Elliot four
councelor Hancock for councel hson for
councelor liot for councelor
Powell councelor Rouse for and councelor
R for that's uh 104 zero against zero
exensions it's carried lovely thank you
very much ladies
[Music]
gentlemen are you joining us now
councilor
[Music]
[Laughter]
Cooper we are we're moving to the next
one
you're not off that
easy um well it
says where are we speakers asked to be
available from 12:45 so yes we can have
lunch yes chair the suggestion is as
that um committee reassembles at one
yeah I think that's
acceptable one o' yep you
chair okay
okay
so good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the second part of our
planning committee meeting this is also
being live streamed and the recording it
will be placed on the council's
website let's turn to the main business
for the afternoon the killer Marsh and
two ashover
applications as you can see each each of
the items has its own report I'm happy
with this and intend to consider them in
that order before we do I would like the
Clark to once again explain for the
benefit of members speakers and those
watching on YouTube how we will deal
with these
applications thank you chair this is the
procedure for considering applications
this
afternoon we will consider the three
applications in the order that they are
set out on the
agenda the chair will introduce the
application then ask the planning
officers to refer members to any lay
comments or updates receiv received
since the agenda was
issued the late item's agenda supplement
has been published on the council's
website and it has been circulated to
you this
morning the planning officers will then
give a brief
presentation these will set out the
application plans and photographs from
the
site after this the chair will ask each
of the
speakers objectors then the applicant or
their agent to speak to the
committee each speaker will have three
minutes to put forward their
views there'll be a reminder given by
the Clark when 30 seconds
remain at the end of a speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions if necessary to clarify any
points they have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application the chair will open up
the meeting for debate by the committee
and determination by a vote the votes
will be taken by roll
call once the application which your
speaker has come to speak on has been
dealt with then they may leave the
meeting if they choose to remain then
they will not be allowed to participate
further from that
point now as you aware this meeting is
being live streamed and recording will
be placed on the council's
website please note that others may
choose to make a copy of it thank you
chair thank you we'll move on to the
application which is
Ned
21976 slfl at killer Marsh and I'll ask
the planning officer to start his
presentation thank you chair um this
application is a resubmission following
the refusal of an application earlier
this year it is a full application for
50 dwellings and includes additional
information on Junction capacity at the
Sheffield Road Primrose Lane Junction
could I have the first slide please
aent thank you uh this is an aerial
photograph of the site Primrose Lane is
to the South and the line of the post
Chesterville Canal uh is to the west of
the
side
this is the submitted Redline site
boundary and also includes um proposed n
mitigation to the
east this is a site layout plan it's the
same layout as previously was refused um
The Proposal fronts onto the route of
the canal to the west and faces out to
the north uh Bungalows are proposed at
the site
entrance there's an area of public open
space to the north of the existing
houses the development is a mix of two
three four and five bed homes and
Bungalow and the site lies within the
settlement aband limits and is also hous
allocation 30 uh under the adopted local
plan next slide
please this shows the proposed new
access into the site
um the unadopted road would be accessed
by a drop
curb some visuals of the POS
houses another visual of the POS houses
uh this is a visual of the units that
would front onto the canal
route this is a photo of the unadopted
section of Primrose Lane
[Music]
a over the site entrance the site
extends to the North and the Bungalow
sighted at the
entrance it's a photo of the junction
with Sheffield Road it's looking right
from down the
hill photo of the junction looking left
up the hill towards the two
schools
this is a photo from The Junction
looking down Primrose
Lane so fero looking back towards the
junction it's a photo of prim's lane
looking back towards the application
s thank you
chair thank you the next part of the uh
proceedings is for the speakers and I
have four speakers on my list and the
first one is the ward member Tony
Lacy you'd like to take the seat at the
[Music]
end okay three minutes when you're ready
good afternoon planning committee uh my
name is Tony Lacy I represent kilar East
and I would like to speak about the
traffic problems and a recent traffic
survey that the developer requested now
that
um survey was done just the first Monday
it was put up when there was a fuel
shortage and it was noted by loal
residents
that a lot of parents walk their
children to
school rather than drove them because
they didn't have sufficient fuel for
their their needs so uh I think you will
find it light and that survey in my
opinion is irrelevant on them dates it
was up for just over 24 hours but less
than
48 okay now that that that lane as you
probably saw in the
photographs is barely sufficient for two
vehicles to pass uh because of local
residents
parking there uh is just the one lane
now if you request another 50 properties
it is going to make it a
nightmare the road needs widening but
there's insufficient room to widen that
road and on that basis I would you know
say to refuse the planning
request um emergency vehicles such as
fire engines ambulances Etc would find
it quite difficult on a day-to-day basis
getting up and down there especially
towards the
evening when most residents are at
home
now there is uh a coule
as you know we've got the schools got
three schools you got the nursery the
junior school and the
infants and it is used for parking by
the parents of the
children so it would
be almost impossible to get out when
you've got two two
vehicles either side of the road
parked um I found it very very difficult
just going around doing my ward business
parking there let alone
uh 30 seconds remain being an emergency
vehicle so I would ask the planning
committee to
refuse the application on them grounds
thank you very much thank you if you
just remain where you're seated are
there any questions councelor
Foster thank you chair uh thank you for
that Council L say uh I know you're the
ward member for that area and thanks for
the information that that you've given
the committee but can you uh have you
spoken to anyone down Prim Rose Lane or
in that area what sort of comments have
you had that might help us make a
decision here things that perhaps like
I'm not thinking of things uh like do
appointments and the usual sort of
comments that we hear when people don't
want de development but what sort of
problems have they said that um that
they might encounter as people that
actually live there well basically
parking is a huge issue there
um
there and especially the unadopted part
of the
road uh up up at the far end that is
basically a track as you probably saw by
the
photographs the better half of it is not
really much better in I don't believe
that an emergency vehicle get down there
in an evening comfortably without
damaging vehicles
thank you
chair thank you are there any further
questions no thank you if you'd like to
take your
seat the second speaker is Jean
[Music]
cookson
no please do you have three minutes when
you're
ready right thank you I am a resident of
Primrose close access off of Primrose
Lane so by submitting the application
the de this new application the
developers completely
disregarded the two main reasons for the
previous rejection the information they
provider still doesn't take account of
the actual situation experienced daily
by residents and other users of the lane
and
close one of the reasons was the density
of the development of 50 properties the
recently approved local development plan
refers to 30
properties uh which had previously been
approved paragraph 7.7 of the report
submitted for this meeting refers to the
efficient use of land surely it means
the profitable use of the land for the
developer killer Marsh residents don't
need a large number of five bedroomed
houses which is about 30 to 40% of the
planning application there's more demand
for more two and three bed properties
but these the smaller properties aren't
profitable for the
developer I was going to mention about
the traffic issues but Mr Lacy's already
done that the proposed Access Road onto
the development will be dangerous and
ignores the parking spaces needed for
current current residents of the unmade
part of the lane there is no provision
for parking spaces that we could see for
the number at least number 17 to 23 on
prim's Lane and future difficulties of
vehicles and pedestrians accessing their
own properties on the lane from number
onwards the proximity of two access
roads from one Narrow Lane that is onto
the new proposed development and the
existing access to Primrose
close and so close together just cannot
be safe for pedestrians or Vehicle
drivers especially delivery and
emergency vehicles and if there is a
serious accident or a fatal one due to
that road layout who will be responsible
this committee the developer the
highways agency no there'll be no blame
there if the developers were told that
Primrose Lane couldn't cope with extra
vehicles for 30 properties in the mid
1980s how is it logical to say that it
could now cope with 150 plus vehicles
for this
development a month ago there was a
vehicle fire on the unmade 30 seconds
remain thank you uh on the unmade up
part of the road roughly where the a
proposed new access will be the fire
engine had to park outside number PR
number 11 primr Lane that blocked all
access on and off of Primrose Lane
Beyond number 11 and onto Primrose
close similar situations have happened
in the past when there's heavy snowfalls
and icy roads we just can't get onto
Primrose Lane to get to our properties
we've had to park elsewhere in the
village this will only get worse with
uh thank you are there any
questions no thank you if you'd like to
take your
seat
I'll apologize in advance if I get this
surname wrong it's David
grona oh well there you
go three minutes when you're ready okay
thank
you my name is David I'm a resident of
Kil lifelong resident of Kil Mar and I
just get on with uh my first concern is
what Provisions have been
made when you start digging out the land
uh and you hit anything that's been
buried there from the norw pit or
anything like that and also the uh
toxins they supposed to be from the
still is not from s has anything been
done about that also
[Music]
uh
also has there been anything about the
carbon
footprint that obviously there be
another say 100
cars and with there been
no uh public transporter is such in Kil
Mar everybody's got to use the cars
again so and also they'll be using the
heating houses and everything like that
is it going to be a
solar panels on the roofs anything like
that to down on carbon
emissions also got concern about pupil
the schools the schools so that they can
cope at the
moment but 50 hours is you'll be talking
if they've got two children a piece
that's 100 children in schools bigger
classrooms less less one toone teaching
supposedly the teachers and in this DNA
is with mental health being such with
children and all that they need more
teaching as as they can as much teaching
as they can one to one not 30 40 to a
class
classroom those are my main concerns
really uh also it'll put pressure I know
we had this before with the doctors if
children like I said pressurized at
school more mental health more going to
the doctors everything everything's
going to be put in a vious ctle if you
know what I mean so that's the basics
that I'd like
to know what's happening with it because
the schools are
just I would say they at the top end now
the level of the the
classrooms so that's
uh 30 seconds remain right also the
24,000 to the schools is that just a
one-off
payment or is it monthly because it's
not it's not uh
very sorry 24,000 to the doctors not the
schools is is that just a one-off
payment because for if you've got the 50
housers you've got two
parents that's 100 then probably that's
200 more resident thank you thank you
are there any questions for the speaker
councilor
Elliot I only have one chair you make
mention of the the pupil teacher ratios
do you know what those ratios are right
now I don't at the moment no not our F
but I know that I've got school teacher
friends and they say they are very on
top level it's just that you may mention
of it could be one in four one one to 40
but but we don't know that we don't
know but obviously it's going to go up
it's not going to go down is it and
obviously if if you're teaching they
need to be looking at the pupils not
pointing out they need they need to be
taught I couldn't agree more I was just
asking if you knew what the you
absolutely D loing they're
teaching the you know what I mean they
not to get taught properly I know
they're trying the best to teach and all
that but if you go a big classroom you
can't concentrate
on individual just got to go the floor
back to my original question you don't
know what the co- is not the moment no I
can't find out for you though yeah that
be nice thank you here I have one
question before councilor Foster comes
in can you just tell me are they both
primary schools or are they primary and
secondary school uh there's no Secondary
School it's Junior in it Junior infant
kill them St jails
and Norwood school so there is a class
limit on what sizes primary schools have
anyway so no more than 30 okay thank you
Council Foster thank you chair uh we've
got in our documents um capacity
assessments of the junction uh made by
uh highways so the County Council yeah
and we've also had previous assessments
of the road uh by the developer which
were commissioned by the developer uh
just as a as someone who lives there
yourself what's your own assessment of
how it is at present do you have
difficulties or do you not have
difficulties with that particular
Junction with the with as it stands now
so just your own opinion and what you've
seen yourself well yes it's just normal
traffic if you know what I mean but it's
it's it's just some days you can't get
in some days you you know can it's just
volume of traffic but the volume of
traffic is only going to increase in if
you putting more hours up it's like
bottom Shuffle road if it stood every
rush hour and obviously the cars stand
there stand there for ages I think a lot
of kilom people have said this they
stand and the fumes on sheff road are
just terrible so you're just going to
get more and more people
that's uh ill there's a lot to see OPD K
but you know what I mean
this I know there's illness everywhere
but it's only going to get worse it's
only
the volume of traffic is
unbelievable and there's more hours
going up on West
supposedly it's just going to be good
lot it's going to be tint whistle all
all over again so I just don't
understand it why this
is thank you for that thank you chair
any further
questions no thank you if you'd like to
take your seat
okay a final speaker for the after
afternoon on this application is Michael
Edgar planning
agent three minutes when you're ready
good afternoon thank you chair excuse me
uh yes my name is Michael Edgar from BLB
planning uh with the planning agents for
the
application um the reason for this
application was to try and address as
much as possible the reasons for refusal
based on the earlier
application to clarify the reason for
the 50 dwellings remaining the same it
is as you've heard it is down to us
believing this makes a more efficient
use of land that's also alluded to in
your officers Report with uh 22
dwellings per hectare still below the
standard 30 dwellings per hectare that
you might
expect uh policy lcu one of the now
adopted local plan does refer to the
site as having uh an estimated capacity
of 32s per hectare and I'm sure uh
councilors will be aware that that was
based on the previous application which
was approved based on the health and
safety executive advice at the time
that's since changed that's set out in
your report as
well in respect to the highways
information we have submitted a junction
capacity assessment um it has also been
corroborated by uh the highways
Authority's video evidence and it
demonstrates as we believed at the
previous application that there would be
no issue in terms of
capacity just turn into some of the
points that have been raised this
morning um this afternoon the uh the
access would actually be redesigned so
the the carriageway is to be extended
North with an increase width to 5.5
meters with a 2 meter wide
footway so that might clarify some
issues around
that in terms of the site investig ation
and the ground conditions there is a
condition set out as well at condition
38 in terms of capacity for
schools we have relied on the local
education Authority's response in that
regard we have not interrogated the
school organization plan we have relied
on doshire County council's position in
that is that they do not require
anything at this
time uh the section 106 contributions do
include a provision for the NHS which on
this occasion unlike the previous
application is directed as a one-off
payment to local Services whereas
previously it was directed to
Chesterfield Royal Hospital we had some
concerns around that but that's since
been clarified 30 seconds
remain I will try and wrap up in that
case chair thank you I think the uh we
welcome the officer's recommendation and
uh I think everything else is summarized
in front of you thank you very
much thank you are there any questions s
Council
CL thank you chair can I just ask you
stated
158 car parking
spaces plus garages will also be
built does the 158 parking spaces
include the garages are is are the
garages extra it's uh 43 of the parking
space garages but 158 on total on plot
on total
thank
you councelor Foster thank you chair
thanks that Mr Edgar my questions around
Anila statement you made about uh
answering uh some of the issues I think
from last time uh when it came to the 30
dwellings and you said that's been
addressed uh because the hsse health and
safety exec the advice on uh the plan
has changed I haven't seen anything like
that in the in the document the only
thing from the hsse is the proposed
development site does not currently
allow in the consultation distance of a
major Hazard uh on page 85 4.8 there's
nothing about their advice changing that
I've seen perhaps you could explain that
to me yes sorry I probably wasn't clear
um in granting the 30 dwellings planning
permission
previously that was where the 30
dwellings came from there was 30
dwellings allowed in the area uh of risk
that the health and safety executive
advised that area of risk has since been
amended hence why we actually made the
application for 50 dwellings previously
refused we haven't s to amend it now the
30 dwelling allocation in the local plan
was as we understood it a a historic
carry-through of the earlier Planning
Commission hence that capacity being
repeated in the
allocation right I've got that but I
can't see where the health and safety
executive changed their their advice on
the plan but thank you for that Mr R I
think it's 2016 that it was the varied
the areas of
exclusion any other questions Council
Club thank you chair I just like to
raise a question around uh the
affordability uh he mentions seven
Bungalow being built on site which two
two bedroomed yes but it also mentions
three three beds are there to be built
on site or are they or is that to be
preped for offsite the extra properties
would be offsite yes so the bungus would
be onsite provision the remainder made
up of section 106 contribution for
offsite provision okay so effectively
they'll just be seven two beds and the
rest will be four and five bed
properties three four and fives yes yeah
okay thank
you okay have we any further
questions no thank you very much thank
you for your time
[Music]
are there any questions for the
officers no
ST okay I'll open the floor for
debate Council Foster thank you chair
I'll make a start
uh my concerns around the reasons uh
this was refused last time and um
without going into the the traffic side
of it which I think they've been looked
at and the county have looked at those
but if we look at the the first reason
which was um it being unacceptable
because it departed from uh the local
plan and it's all around the the
sustainability uh which was uh that was
one of the key things for me and it's
something that IOP Field's been
addressed here and I don't think it's
something we discussed as
sustainability uh when you look at the
local plan which is uh which has been
based on that and I think Council bar
has been quite involved in that more
more than any of us and he'll have a a
good idea of that it's that that defines
it and it's for all of us it defines it
as being sustainable so it's in there
with the with the 30 uh properties and
defined as being sustainable when you
look at what sustainable
means uh the mppf states that the
sustainable development is a golden
thread running through both planning and
decision making so it's running through
the local plan but it's also running
through this decision uh making that
we're doing here uh sustainable
development is development that meets
the needs of the present without
compromising the ability of future
generations to meet their own needs and
that means we must balance three things
environmental social and economic needs
together all three of those and that's
what our local plan does uh a recent
case that went to uh the high court for
150 new homes uh with East staffire bur
Council it was decided there that the
concept of sustainable development is
predominantly implemented by the local
plan and decisions to approve
developments inconsistent with that plan
could only been made in exceptional
cases and that's where we are here I
feel and I don't feel there's in in this
case that there is no exceptional case
for departing from our local plan it's a
local plan that we've only just fought
over All Of Us Together full council
with people voting for it against it uh
and some people abstaining but e either
way now this is now our plan it's a plan
that belongs to the council and in the
plan it's got that 30 homes because the
30 homes is sustainable and there's no
reason in my mind from looking at this
application we should be departing from
that there's no and if you look at what
what they said in the high court there
is no exceptional case here to depart
from 30 30 to 50
that's the key thing uh one of the main
reasons seems to be to be to as we've
heard earlier for there to be a more
efficient use of the land well I've got
that yeah we can put another 20 houses
on there and it can be more profitable
and another 20 families can live in
there absolutely but is it sustainable
in my mind it's not sustainable and so
the one of the reasons we it got refused
last time is still still stands to me
with the same policies only the polishes
are now no longer an emerging local they
are our local plan now and it belongs to
us and we must own it so for me it's uh
it's certainly not sustainable thank you
chair any further questions Council
Armitage yes uh thank you CH I must uh
agree with everything council boss has
said uh the other thing which uh do have
always brought up with this development
and that's the close close proximity to
Viola uh they have some pretty terrible
toxic chemicals on that side and part of
this are part of this uh development on
both of them the 30 and this one will be
affected by it and it's worked out I
mean we've got the actual uh diagram of
what the area uh the proximity of it
does but it doesn't take into a uh
uh U it doesn't take in the prevailing
wind and there was I don't know I
remember on the 31 that we approved
sometime ago uh a counselor said that
there's a wind sock on site uh and he
wondered what it was for well it's it's
to monitor which way is the winds uh
going
uh and whether or not uh properties in
the area have to be uh uh well evacuated
or window shut because of some of these
chemicals some of these chemicals are so
deadly uh because I did a lot of
research before uh the one before the
one for 30 that no one knows what these
chemicals smell like CU one whiff of
them will kill you and that's
uh and I did take uh well I compared it
with
what
a well actually an organic chemist told
me about these chemicals they are very
lethal and I think it's just ridiculous
to put these houses so near to this
site and uh as regards the local plan
it's 30 houses and anything above is
just not
sustainable okay I know Richard's got
his hand up happy to come in after
Richard if um can add to anything he
says chair happy come back on some of
those points as
appropriate okay we'll start with
Richard thank you chair
um I think firstly we need to recognize
yes the the local plan has just been um
has just been Ed and kilar is recognized
as being one of our foremost
sustainable settlements chair
sorry if I just point out I thought this
part unless I can be corrected I thought
this part of the meeting it was to
debate between ourselves I thought we'd
already done the answering asking
questions of officers is that not the
case I did ask four questions to the
officers and this is I think they just
want a point of clarification to make it
easier so um it's entirely up to the
group whether they want to listen to the
officers or not I will take a reading
from what I think
approach
yeah yeah my point there chair is that
we we've already heard from officers we
had a chance to ask questions of
officers and it's at this point that we
all debate between ourselves otherwise
you might find you've got uh officers
debating with with members okay point
taken so off okay I'll take the offices
at the end if we just finish our debate
Council
Barker thank you chair yeah yeah H I
think we should listen to offic the end
and the can advis us I'm tending to to
to swing behind uh what's been said uh I
mean obviously like like the other one I
weren't party to the decision when the
30 properties were agreed but that seems
to be an historic thing so uh obviously
all the debates around traffic and
access roads and parking we'll probably
dealt with at that meeting so I think uh
I think we take that as as as R if you
like but on this one I I take the the
point that 30
properties it's not an ideal place to
put that field is with for Access and
whats of other things it's not a great
field to develop but that's been
approved you know historically but I
don't think out above 30 is it's not
going to make it any better so I don't
know where we'll end up with this and
we'll listen to officers advice
regarding because it weren't really
explained very clearly how it went up
from 30 to 50 and why so they might
explain that but my good reaction is is
not to not support this because it's too
many
okay thank you is there any others
comment councilor Elliot thank you chair
chair the only reason I said I'd like to
hear the officer's comments as well
after I agree with I agree with Mark to
be honest we had we had gone down that
rout but I'd like some clarification
because I did sit through the original
application and I thought that violia
part had mitigated the circumstances
around the chemicals uh and given us a
zonal circumferential map to say where
you know where the word parts and the
best parts were irrespective of
prevailing winers so I would like to
hear what they've got to say about
that councelor
CL thank you chair um my my comment goes
back to uh same as councilor Foster I
think from this this one's this one's
difficult for me uh and my concern is
that we have just adopted the local plan
uh and if we start departing from the
numbers within the local plan where will
that where will that end uh I mean this
is this is an extra 20 if we move to
another site could be an extra 100 uh do
we do we stick to what we've said in the
local plan or do we uh we just go the
alternative um it concerns me it does
concern me thank you chair okay
councilor
Foster yeah thank you chair yet on that
uh I think there may be in the future
times when we have to uh uh leave the
local plan and I think that's always
being the case uh but you have to follow
the rules that that show how you lead
the local plan and for me the argument
here when you talk about sustainable
development it's not met those
exceptional circumstances so we might
have to depart if other people here feel
on balance that it's that this reaches
uh you know those those exceptional
circumstances my own View and it's only
one View oh we've heard from a few
others uh is that these aren't
exceptional circumstances so it's uh so
for me it's as clear as that they maybe
in the future time times we have to
depart from the local plan but not now
because that there have been there's
been no exceptional circumstances given
to us apart from more efficient use of
the
land okay thank you Council
Armitage yeah I would also like to point
out this is a a Greenfield site and uh
as far as local plan concerned if we're
going to start building on Green Field
sites then uh I think it's a a bad State
of
Affairs the plan's been uh voted on and
it's now law and there's no point going
off it and let's face it if they go to
appeal on this which they probably will
do uh the officer the inspector will go
with what the local plan uh actually
says and the local plan says 30 houses
and we must uh respect
that thank you okay now if we're all
happy I'm going to ask the officers to
come back with some clarifications on
the points made is there any objection
to
that no thank you we'll start with
Richard thank you chair um yes firstly
you the local plan has just been adopted
and so can be given full
weight kilar is one of our for most
sustainable settlements this is a site
that is allocated for residential use
within the confines of the development
limits of
kilar the every allocated site at the
time it's allocated in the local plan is
given an indicative number of houses
that is that could be put on that and uh
when you add up those uh those
indicative um sums it gives us an idea
as to whether or not we're allocating
sufficient land to meet the number of
houses that are um that need to be
delivered during the local plan
period now 30 uh in this instance and
indeed all the numbers on any allocated
site is not a maximum number and it is
in this instance it would have been a
ref ction of the fact that planning
permission had recently been granted for
a development of 30 houses had a
development um had planning permission
previously been granted for 50 houses I
have no doubt that 50 houses would have
been the um the indicative number that
would have been included for this site
on the um in in the
plan now if we are going to look at um
saying that 50 is not um acceptable here
then you have to identify the the harm
that is being created by having an
additional 20 houses now the highway
issues have shown that uh that that harm
is not being um uh caused as a result of
this this
number and and so when it comes to if
they get to an appeal but you know
whether it's the planning inspector or
the planning committee the the fact that
this is an allocated site in one of our
most um uh uh sustainable locations is a
very strong uh presumption in favor of
the development whether it is Greenfield
or not a lot of sites that have been
allocated in the plan are indeed
Greenfield but that it has been
identified for for this particular
purpose so if there's any reason to go
contrary to what the plan is saying as
opposed to just simply the indicative
number of houses that have been
identified then you need to identify the
harm that is actually being created as a
result of this which was would have been
unforeseen and at the time when the uh
when the plan was being prepared and
subsequently
adopted thank you does anyone want to
ask any questions of
Richard no want me to clarify the issues
with regard to viia and just comment on
the highway matters
[Music]
chair sorry Adrian I didn't catch that I
just just asked if you'd like me to try
and advise members on the issues that
particular Council arm's raised with
regards to violia and also comment on
any the highway issues that have been
raised okay
um you want to go
forward yes uh I I would uh ask Adrian
about the uh level of toxicity uh from
that plant because it's all right
looking at sustainable but if the wind
Chained and you kill them all off you
know let's uh let's let's be factual
about it yeah just on that that issue
chair members some members may recall
previous applications where the hsse
have advised that no more than 30
dwellings should be accommodated on this
site and that was when their zones of
inluence of the theia plant were
different and and greater than those now
chair in terms of that issue in
particular as has been discussed earlier
on Mr Eder made it made the point that
the zones of impact are now redrawn
further to review of that issue by
violia after those applications were
considered and as I think Phil mentioned
earlier the the site Now lies outside
those zones so there is no reason in
terms of health and safety advice why a
larger number than 30 units couldn't be
accommodated on the site so hopefully
that's helped chair although I'm I'm no
expert I'm afraid on toxicity what we've
gone on in this case is the advice we've
got from the hsse and just on the the
highway issues there's been quite a lot
of debate about that chair and members
may recall the last time the matter was
discussed there was concern that excuse
me there was no capacity assessment of
the junction of Primrose Lane with the
main Highway Network well that has been
a change in terms of the information
submitted with this application and that
has been assessed by the highway
Authority as well and we've set those
conclusions out in the report we produce
for members chair and as members I'm
sure will note the highway Authority
have accepted the submission and the
information provided they don't feel
there is any Highway reason to resist
the application indeed they believe that
there is still some capacity at that
Junction Network that could accommodate
actually more Vehicles than the 50 units
that you considering this afternoon
would deliver thank you I've got
councelor CL and then I'll come back to
councelor AR come back yeah it's I
remember the planning application Adrian
we also had a very detailed thing from
violia of what chemicals were uh stored
there which we don't have now and the
other thing is uh when it was first
muted uh we had this uh this Zone around
it and it uh seemed to cover a lot more
of the area uh than uh is uh well than
the modified one which we have now and
it struck me then it's rather strange
that suddenly this area of uh what
potential toxicity had shrunk somewhat
but the chemicals were still there
you want to come back to that agent but
I think we've gone and done chemicals
and what have you to
death I can't anything more than not
said previously on that chair
so thank you I've got Council CL then I
come to
council thank you chair I just need a
bit of clarity because I'm getting
slightly confused here um
30 houses that were put into the local
plan it's a bit of a chicken and egg
were they considered for the local Plan
before the first application or after
the first application think that the
first application was in
2004 uh and the local plan started way
before that
2009 have you any clarification on those
dates do do you want me to yes please
Richard okay um all I can um say is that
uh the
um the the plan was submitted to the
publication draft of the plan was
submitted through examination
2018 um the uh exactly when 30 was um
put for that number um I I can't tell
you without going through a great deal
of further research but um there is
reference as you'll see to a 2017 huning
permission relating to to 30 um and that
may well be what has been used to to
show what is possible on the site but as
I say all the numbers in the plan are
indicative and I would uh I doubt that
uh many of them will be coming forward
with exactly that number when it comes
to a detailed
application Council f chair I must
protest this is not on this this is all
back to front I'm really not impressed
by this at all absolutely you know the
officers had a chance to State their
case as I'm going to put it earlier on
in this process not at this point what I
might wonder is when we moved on to the
next part of the meeting are they going
to be putting a motion forward or is
that just for us I might be you might
accuse me of being factious there but
I'm getting tied out no I wasn't going
to accuse you of being factious I asked
if members had any objections to hearing
clarification from officers that might
be the case chair but a lot of what
we've heard weren't answers you know
that what they were doing is going
through this case again they weren't
answering questions they were going
through it again and what they felt were
relevant which is completely different
we had questions about traffic and we
had questions about chemicals we didn't
have questions about
sustainability all right okay well I
think we'll move on from that we've all
had uh enough of that so the floor is
now open for a
moment
okay now before I can I just can I just
come in there please I was going to say
before I'm shouted down yet again this
is from advice from our legal department
yeah yeah I've just got to say that it
is completely appropriate for officers
to come in at any time during a a debate
in order to put forward their um
interpretation of the the situation and
particularly where they feel that um
their advice is is needed by the the
planning committee whether it's asked
for or Not by the members of the
planning committee it is completely
appropriate for for officers to come in
at any time to provide their their view
on on any particular
matter and members should be prepared to
listen and um they don't have to agree
to member uh to the the officers but
they should be prepared to listen and
consider the advice provided by by the
the
offices thank
you right we'll move on now to a motion
councilor Foster yeah I'm happy to
propose that we don't accept this uh
application uh on uh I'd happily hear
from others here but primarily on that
it's unsustainable and it that it
doesn't follow uh the local plan if you
look at the top of page 83 in the pike
uh we can look at the same writing there
there and it's all about the departure
from the development so that's what I'm
looking at for guidance for office is
what I'm putting forward obviously we
would exclude uh the previous local plan
which is uh which is mentioned in there
so if we if we take that part out of it
the rest is pretty clear so that's what
i' be looking for so it's all around it
it been uh
unsustainable which like I said uh when
I first spoke
earlier that 50 being too much for that
particular area and obviously the uh the
policies are in there for the new local
plan I don't know if anybody else is
interested if if they are similar minded
on looking at something to do with the
traffic but
[Music]
uh okay I have a motion on the floor and
it's been seconded by councilor
Armitage chairman I just just clarify
before you move to the vote just the the
exact wording of that please I'm just
going to ask Alan to go through it all
for us okay sh from what I could pick up
there it's to refuse Planning Commission
against officer
recommendations essentially uh because
of the issues in terms of um the uh
numbers of uh dwellings uh and how this
actually exceeds the figure within the
local plan is that the essence of it
members or would you like more more
thank you and that it's not sustainable
we mentioned that yeah and that they it
lacks sustainability thank
you just for for clarification Council
Foster mentioned the two reasons the top
of page 83 in the report and I note what
he said with regard to the
issue of the tith Northeast doia local
plan publication draft and that can be
easily altered and remove any reference
to the formerly adopted Northeast ARA
local plan so um I think cast Foster's
saying that the same wording will
otherwise apply just need clarification
again chair as to whether it's both that
reason and reason number two which
relates to Highway issues and if it is
in relation to Highway issues the
submission of the additional information
has been provided so members were minded
to be concerned about that there would
need be some alteration in the wording
to address that additional information
that has been received CH so it's that
those couple areas of clarification I'd
be grateful for so we can be sure if
members do resolve to refuse the
application we're carrying out the
requirements of the committee in in
proper
fullness Council Foster yeah if I
understand yeah well we can include both
those reasons then yeah uh and also it
mentions at the top page each seen that
first paragraph uh about it affecting
the character of the area as well but
yes include the traffic one too then
please yeah the character of the area is
contained in recent one chair so so um
we take out the reference to the
publication draft and put in the current
local plan take any reference to the
former local plan and then amend the
wording in the second reason in the same
vein respect to former local plan and
newly adopted local plan and also
respect to the not accompanied by
capacity assessment it would just be
that members are concerned that addition
vehicle movements would be severely
harmful to an impact on highway safety
so in effect take out the first sentence
of Reason number
two yes please okay thank you right
after all that are we ready for a vote
and we'll go by roll call sorry chair
can I just be absolutely clear councilor
Foster moves the motion who was the
seconder council Armitage Council
Armitage thank
you do you allow me to
proceed um and apologies counc on the
spot are you intending on voting on this
item you halfway through the
discussion would you would you like me
to call your name to vote
okay um members if you could clearly
state for against or abstain Council
Armitage Council
Barker Council KF four councelor Cooper
four councelor Elliot four councelor
Foster for councelor harson for
councelor liot for councelor Powell
against councelor Rous
abstain councelor Ru against and
councelor W
windley chair that's eight votes for two
against two abstention the motion is
carried to refuse thank you thank you
every body and if you'd like to depart
as quickly as possible so we can move on
to the next
application we're slightly ahead of
schedule yes chair can we just have a
couple of minutes break I'm not quite
sure whether we've got all the speakers
here yet yeah so if we back for five P
two yes chair thank you break
okay
I think everyone can agree with
that okay um the application before us
this afternoon item 8 is Ned
sl21 sl01
025 slfl for
ashover um over to
the
officer are they
back we're all on board I'm here chair I
hope and I'm
here I'm here I was on mute my apologies
can you hear me yep off you go Alice
okay thank you chair this application is
to regularize the construction of two
private cons at land to the southeast of
Siberia Cottages sidot pill Dary Moore
late representations have been received
from the neighbor Mr Moore and are in
the late representations document for
members to have a look at the line
subject to the application is outlined
in Orange on this plan you can see the
Dalmore Plantation to the Northeast Dal
road to the Northwest and the
neighboring property Charlestown to the
South uh next slide
please this is the red line plan for the
site the land surrounding to the north
and west belongs to the applicant the
land to the immediate South belongs to
neighbor at Charles toown next slide
please the application is to regularize
the size of two private ponds which were
permitted under planning application
17002 79 FL the title of this
application was application for the
construction of a private pond this plan
shows the size and design of the ponds
as approved as you can see they were
reasonably small and of a sorry and of a
design which the wildlife trust was
supportive of due to the curvy edges
being attractive to plants and other
Wildlife next slide
please this drawing shows the ponds as
they have been
constructed both ponds have been screed
increased in scale and depth and have a
more circular shape than those
originally approved the applicant has
indicated to me that this was due to the
Topography of the land and the
challenges encountered whilst carrying
out the
work as the principle of this
development was accepted as a
consequence of the 2017 application
planning considerations here as to
whether the new design of the ponds AB
above and beyond what has already been
approved has an unacceptable impact on
the landscape in this area and if the
benefits of the proposal still outweigh
the loss of the agricultural land and
next slide
please the the applicant already carried
out a lot of tree planting on the land
which helps to screen it uh screen the
ponds from public View and also adds to
its biodiversity value the original
application allowed the private
ponds
sorry the the original application
allowing the private ponds um
prohibited the stocking of those fish
stocking of those ponds with fish for
commercial purposes
only subsequently the applicant has
stocked the pond with fish but he uses
it for private fishing
only the following photographs are a
selection taken from those shown at the
site visit
yesterday this slide is taken from the
forest commission Woodland where there
is Public
Access uh next slide uh this slide is
also from the same
location and the next one please this is
taken from the Aral field to the
Northeast you can see the distance
between the ponds and the neighboring
property at Charles
toown next slide
please these two slides give a a sense
of the level of the planting that has
been carried out by the application
applicant so it's this one and the next
one officer and darbishire Wildlife
trusts are of the opinion that whilst
the original design was optimal for
biodiversity the ponds are as built
still provide an important habitat for
wildlife DWT have expressed that on
balance particularly given that the
ponds have become well established due
to the passing of time the rting the
ponds back to the original design would
be more harmful to Wildlife than the
changes that have been made further
officers are of the opinion that the
increased size of the ponds over and
above what was approved does not cause
harm to the character of the countryside
or the important landscape therefore
they meet the requirements of policies
ss9 and SDC three of the local plan and
also recommending approval subject to
conditions thank you chair thank you
Alice okay we'll move on to our first
Speaker for the afternoon on the
application Mr Paul
Kelly Mr Kelly you have three minutes
when you're
ready
Mr Kelly can you switch your microphone
on sorry and if you want to take your
mask off you may do so
okay start again uh in 2017 we were
granted permission to construct a
private pond not a wildlife Pond the
attached conditions did not state that
the main Pond could not be stocked with
fish in 2018 we were granted permission
to erect a replacement building for
mixed Agriculture and Leisure use not an
agricultural Barn throughout the process
we have been completely transparent with
planning neighbors and often inquiring
members of the public regarding our
intentions and
objectives these being to better utilize
a 3 Acre parcel of extremely poor land
provide some accessible pleasure fishing
for my 87y old disabled Farm father
create a modest native deciduous
Woodland within a predominantly Pine
forested area establish a body of water
that would help compensate the demise of
the nearby flash Dam where feasible
enhance local habitat and ecology
restore the historic dry stone walls
preserve restore and complement the
character of the local area these
objectives to augment the ongoing works
on our overall landh holding which to
date have included rebuilding 1.6 km of
dry stone wall removal of half an acre
of invasive roaded dendrum planting more
than 800 native trees Crown lifting
operations to effect longterm
preservation of more than
260 historic beach trees and provision
of numerous bat and bird boxes during
our 20-year residency we have always
referenced the Northeast arish local
plan the ashover neighborhood plan and
environmental issues featured in the
media whilst include guidance from the
Woodland trust darbishire
Wildlife our appointed planning
consultant and
ecologist in contrast to the many
compliments received from nearby
tourist-based
Enterprises neighbors and numerous
members of the public my partner and I
have been deeply disappointed and
intimidated that suddenly two years
after the establishment of the ponds The
One and Only objector our neighbor has
employed extreme exaggeration and use
misleading statements to discredit
discredit us personally and our efforts
30 seconds remain statements which in
instances I've been advised are liess
however on a positive note we know with
our passion and commitment we will
continue to achieve a positive
contribution to the area as recently
recognized by Ash Ashfield District
Council and featur on let's go Peak
District's social media pages so I
politely ask the committee to support
our
applications thank you chair thank you
Mr Kelly can I just for clarification
you have two ponds but only one is
stopped for fishing correct thank you
very much are there any further
questions councilor Elliot thank you
chair Mr Kelly yeah um I read absolutely
I'm absolutely amazed that Ashfield
Council of actually come to you as a
private resident to ask if they can use
your ponds as a model for Nottingham sh
when building any more ponds so uh could
you just Enlighten us on to what you've
done to encourage Wildlife to your
wildlife habitat to The Ponds to the
walls to the tree Etc uh it's been a
combination of many things we've
obviously planted trees we've installed
wildlife refuges on the site uh we've
got more trees to
plant um we've planted native uh water
plants um it's it's all the walls on the
site we've restored those fully we're
still working on another
760 walls to be rebuilt they all provide
habitat um we've got another acre and a
half of raded dendrum to remove uh more
Woodland management to improve upon that
it's been a combination of things
councelor no one Silver Bullet I'm
afraid and also I've had in the two
years and it seems to be that long it's
gone on i' this last month or so I've
had so many phone calls asking or or
trying to Lobby me to support this and
these are your neighbors who are
actually in support of everything you've
done uplifting the trees for future
gener Generations uh and so on and so
forth um is is it just the one neighbor
that's that's actually because I only
read um when I when I read our our
websites I only read that one person is
objecting to it is that sadly that is
correct okay thank you Mr Mr Kelly thank
you councelor Foster thank you chair uh
afternoon Mr Kelly good afternoon um on
page 127 of the pike it speaks about a
condition under
4.26 a condition that's imposed in 2017
preventing keeping the fish for
commercial uh purposes members consider
that any fishing should only be open to
members of the household is that
absolutely the case there's only your uh
members of your household my members of
my household and and two or three of my
father's disabled friends from his old
fishing club on occasions to answer your
question more
fully um I've logged carefully last year
and this year's fishing activities this
year a period of today
347 days the pond was only fished on 37
occasions sometimes for an hour for
maximum 5 hours so that represents a
utilization of that period of
10.66% previous year
2020 that figure was
10.62% that goes down lower if you
actually allocate the actual hours that
are fished against let's say an8 hour
day during daylight hours it's down to
something like
4.3%
utilization uh thanks for that so 37
occasions that that's in that's in the
last year that figure yes correct to dat
yes yeah perhaps my concern is around
that it's not exactly strictly in
keeping with uh that condition uh open
to members of the household and the
applicant's property uh which we talk
about uh members of a an older fishing
club so two or three friends personal
friends of my
fathers and I would Define commercial
fishing activity is for paying
customers you not
think it's not for me to answer that
question you answer my questions but
thanks
um it's it's members of the household
and it mov moves away from that that's
perhaps my my concern around that that's
all but I think you've answered it clear
so thank you for that thank
you I've read through this pack on on
more than one occasion could you tell
the committee whether anybody and and I
know you've um used DWT and and every
other effective body you can use for
information on how best to go ahead with
the fish with with the planting of the
pond with the planting the native trees
has anybody stumped up any money to help
you with this no it's all been privately
funded sir fantastic thank
you are there any further
questions no thank you thank you Mr
Kelly if you'd like to take your seat
thank you
chair um next speaker is Mr John
church we just reverse the order if
that's all right with I have no problem
with that at all so it's Simon bra
thank you chair and good afternoon
counselors uh my name is Simon brain I
act on behalf of the applicant as a
chartered abor culturalist and eological
consultant of 25 years experience and
the managing director of an
environmental planning consultancy
employing 15 people I started my career
in nature conservation 30 years ago was
a warden for the National Trust I
currently advis in construction
infrastructure environmental sectors and
private individuals to government
departments biodiversity is something
close to all of our hearts the beauty
and wonder of the natural world is often
the cement which bonds all of us
together and therefore the government
are introducing the environment Bill to
transform environmental governance
protection and
enhancements local authorities are
responding by developing plans for
biodiversity net
gain biodiversity net gain assessment
into planning application
processes this application is to
regularize this application to
regularize is supported by a
biodiversity net gain assessment which
verify the ecological improvements is
providing a near 165% net gain for
biodiversity if refused A near 165% loss
will apply the removal of the existing
and proposed habitat features would be
contrary to National planning policy
framework and local policy a failure to
regularize this application shall have a
devastating species level
impact with regard to protected birds
and mammals which will be lost and
opportunities for expense expansion of
reptile Aven invertebrate Aquatic and
amphibian communities would also be
lost the key biodiversity points of this
application are it has a huge percentage
net gain for biodiversity as measured by
a defom metric it is supported by the
darish of wildlife
trust and it and it carries planning
officer
support the biodiversity planning
Arguments for this scheme weigh heavily
in favor of regularization the scheme
hugely extends government biodiversity
assessment thresholds and has the
support of the local planning
Authority's own advisor darish Wild live
trust should the committee be REM be
minded to refuse the application a
considerable loss of biodiversity will
occur and I request the committee to act
with the best interests of local
biodiversity local plans and National
policy 30 seconds remain I would urge
the committee to consider whether
returning a biodiversity hotspot back to
a wet arable field is a suitable outcome
for any of the interested parties
thank you chair thank you are there any
questions councelor Elliot thank you
chair um 165% gain in biodiversity
that's correct counselor that's that's
absolutely massive could I mean as a kid
I used to swim in Flash Dam which used
to be probably 500 yards from there okay
which was a a huge Dam that attracted
Wildlife until we jumped and swam about
in it although you could say we were
probably part of it and I just like your
take on it as as an experienced guy how
much biodiversity would be lost by flash
Dam
shutting do would you have an idea on
the impact of
that honestly flash dam is not a site
I've been to it's not a site I know but
what I can quantify for the counselors
is quite what a 165% plus gain is we we
we've carried out so far in the last two
years about
2022 biodiversity net gain assessments
the greatest we've had so far is about
40% that is based on a open Mosaic
habitat that's been transferred into
housing and the P designation was about
30 35% of the site so a really quite a
large public open space designation on a
allocated housing site and that really
is the only reason why we we've got to
40% other than that I would say 80 maybe
85% of the net gain assessments I
currently Carry Out Show net
loss and the only way for applicants at
the moment or one of the most successful
ways for applicants at the moment to get
to Net Zero is to effectively pay an
environmental tax through section one of
six
agreement
and whilst my personal opinion is the
environment bill is floating in this in
this way the applicant on this
occasion has such a huge net
gain it seems to me as an ecologist
fical that we wouldn't consider that
appropriate yeah
no oh no brainer yet yeah chair just
just just so the gentleman knows flash
dam was probably 10 times the size of
this Pond and so that probably gives us
a little bit of an insight into to how
much we lost and one person coming back
in with the for side to do what he's
doing gives us a little bit of a gain
back on something that we've lost thank
you any further questions thank you very
much thank you
thank Mr church if you're
[Music]
ready three minutes when you're ready
thank you chair um I appreciate this
opportunity to address the committee um
I to make it clear that I'm a fellow of
the real toown planning Institute and
that I practice locally in both local
government and in private practice for
the best part of 50 years now have
advised and represented the applicant Mr
Kelly with regard to planning matters
both within this district and outside
the district on several occasions and if
I can initially comment very briefly in
reply to just two of the serious
allegations made by the agreed neighbor
and his latest submissions that were
reported to you uh as an update this
afternoon as a first consideration I'm
able to State and I State emphatically
that to my certain knowledge no
additional foundations have been
provided to facilitate the construction
of any extension to the building that's
the subject of one of today's two
applications I have to say to the
committee that that allegation is
frankly
scous secondly so far as the retention
of the ponds is concerned I was present
where Mr Kieran Houston of the darish
wildlife trust in pursuance of the
council's development management
consultation with the trust visited the
site and subsequently advised on
existing and future ecology and
biodiversity considerations in the
spring of this year the ponds were
contrary to the neighbors objection
teaming with amphibians on that occasion
as Mr hon was able to observe the
application the applicant is I can
assure the commit
committed to implementing the trust
subsequent advice which has been
appreciated as a matter of priority all
the developments and environmental
improvements at more house irrespective
of whether or not planning permission
has been required for them has been
carried out to a very high standard and
I submit that this applies equally to
the developments to which the two
applications before you today relate the
management of this land has therefore
benefited the locality considerably
rather than detracting from it its
inherent quality in any way in my
professional opinion you've been
provided by officers with Comprehensive
balance reports in which the application
details their background the key local
plan and neighborhood plan policies and
other material considerations that
should apply have been appropriately and
cogun set out the recommended conditions
are relevant to the proposals and they
are reasonable in all
respects I therefore commend the
recommendations on each application to
you for your favorable consider
consideration and I hope that the
committee will decide accordingly thank
you thank you are there any
questions no thank you if you'd like to
take your
seat are there any questions for the
officer
we are we considering both applications
together at the moment because it's just
one it's just this one yes yeah this is
just about the point
yes are there any questions for the
officer no thank you very much be very
sure before before we go down that road
okay the floor's now open for debate
councilor
liot i' just like to say I'm full of
admiration having just planted 300 trees
and I've got another 300 native trees to
plant tomorrow I'm in great admiration
because it's it's it's hard graft as
well as the expense so um yes I'm in
full admiration for what they've
achieved thank you any any F councilor
Armitage well I visited this site
together with Peter Elliot and uh you
know it's I must admit it was with
admiration because it it is fantastic
that what he's done and created this uh
this Wildlife Sanctuary nothing else and
it was teaming with wild life even
though there was snow on the
ground any other
comment councelor Ellen oh sorry chair I
thought you'd already moved on no I
don't have any more comments I was I was
just going to move off recommendation
and I'd like to Second
those anyone else any other com no I'd
like to take a vote on that then
please thank you chair Council Armitage
for Council Barker four councelor clu
four councelor Cooper four councel
Elliot four councelor Foster four
Council haror for Council liot for
Council Powell Council Rouse for Council
Ruff for and castle windley for 12 for
zero against zero abstentions it's
carried thank you very much and we'll
start
the just wait for a a member to leave
thank you very much
and then we'll move on to our next
application final one of the day
n211
slfl again at
ashover and we'll start with the
officer's presentation off you go Alice
thank you
chair this application is to vary
condition two of planning permission
18001 177 FL to allow for the increased
footprint alterations to refight and
changes to external details and internal
layout of a replacement building the
application is a resubmission of
forl which was refused in
2020 uh as before the site is known as
the land to Southeast of Siberia
Cottages synip Hill daring Moore again
late representations have been received
from the neighbor at Charlestown Mr
Moore and these are in the late
representations parks for members to
read the site is here outlined in Orange
as mentioned before you can see the
forestry commission Plantation the road
and the neighboring land to the South
the neighboring property Charles toown
is approximately 35 m to the boundary of
the site and 110 M to to the
building next slide
please again this is the red line plan
for the the site the applicant's other
land is outlined in blue next slide
please this slide shows the plans
approved after a non-material Amendment
application in
2019 and next slide
please and this slide shows the building
as
constructed and next slide
please for clarity this slide shows the
plans alongside each other the changes
to the building includes a 1 meter
increasing in the height of the building
from 5 m to 6 M creating a steeper roof
pitch and Verge detailing as well as an
increase to the overall footprint of the
building from five 5 m by 5.8 M that's
29 square meters to 5.3 M by 6.3 M which
is 33 square m respectively this amounts
to an approximate 133% footprint
increase changes are proposed to the
fation which give the building a
slightly less agricultural
feel uh next slide
please changes are proposed to the
outside of the building which include a
disabled parking space to the north and
a disabled access ramp to the double
doors this is to facilitate use of the
building and the ponds for fishing by
the applicant's elderly father next
slide
please as discussed in the previous
application building is surrounded by
considerable new planting as well as the
two
ponds The Following photos were taken
from the site visit which members
attended
yesterday these photos were taken of the
building in 2020 and show the changes to
the design and the fenestration so
there's just two more of these Aid
please and then the last one that's it
and then the next slide
please this slide shows the building as
viewed from the publicly accessible
Woodland to the East and Northeast
next slide
please this slide shows the building as
viewed from the agricultural land to the
north and next slide please this is a
closer view taken from the agricultural
land next slide please these slides show
the building within the site so there
you can see um uh Charles Town to the
rear there to the South and the smaller
pond in front of the building and then
the next slide please
that's it a bit closer
up and I think there's one
more that's it it is considered that the
changes to the building above and beyond
those approved in the 2018 application
and the 2019 non-material amendments do
not amount to changes which cause harm
to the character of the countryside or
the important landscape in this area
further due to the relatively small
change in the comparison to in
comparison to the building as a whole
couple with the distance from the
neighboring property at Charlestown the
changes to the building do not have a
significant impact on the privacy and
amenity of neighbors as such offices are
of the opinion that the application
meets the requirements of policies ss9
and sdc3 and therefore should be
approved subject to the conditions as
outlined in the report to members thank
you chair thank you and here we go again
Mr Kelly if you'd like to take the
table thank you chair uh I have no
statement to make other than my previous
statement purely to Encompass the two U
applications into one and to save time
for the
meeting if there's any questions perhaps
any any councelor Foster thank you chair
thanks again Mr Kelly um yeah uh when we
look at page 139
2.11 uh it's been resubmitted because
it's come to unnoticed that some members
of the planning committee
considered that not all material
consideration considerations were fully
discussed and taken into account before
the motion to refuse permission was
determined the application is
redeposited
accordingly um I remember being here uh
when when this when this came was
refused and while I don't have my other
papers to compare with me uh I I can't
recall as there's anything new here
would you like to point out anything any
new material con considerations that you
consider weren't considered if that
makes any sense anything here so it's
about the statement in
2.11 give you a chance to a think of
that answer uh uh and just repeat it
more clearly if I can right it's it's
about um some
members uh consider that not all
material considerations were fully
discussed uh I thought they were can you
think of any because youve resubmitted
it what wenten for the discussed um
perhap my my um planning consultant will
will elucidate better but purely and
simply to answer your question um we we
did have some subsequent visits from
councilors to site um and uh the
comments that I remember most vividly
are the fact that the initial
presentation made by the case officer
didn't really reflect the scale of the
site and the position of the building
and as a result of that um it was
suggested that we might resubmit that
for further
consideration since that time we've done
nothing on the building whatsoever to
change anything um at all so the size
and the scale yeah the size and the
scale has all remained as it was not
touched the building at all subject to
this than for that next meeting thanks
thank you chair thank you are there any
other questions thank you Mr Kelly thank
you
chair gentlemen which one of you is
going first this
[Music]
time thank you chair um my presentation
as you all have heard was really
intended to cover both both applications
but just to answer the the points that
um the counselor has just made I
certainly got the impression at the
previous meeting when planning
commission was refused that there had
not been a full appreciation or
understanding of the materiality of the
changes that there were between uh the
originally approved proposal and the
substitute proposal that was before the
members on that day now um Alice lockit
has explained this afternoon in
dimensional terms what those changes are
um I I don't believe that they are
material certainly in the context of The
Wider land landscape and in certainly in
terms of the square metage of the
building and the additional area that
was created by the
changes um it was because we um were
were reviewing the way that we would
tackle the situation that we found
ourselves in that um I suggested to Mr
Kelly that it would be preferable on
this occasion not to appeal the
council's decision but to seek the
reconsideration that has led to this
application so that's the
straightforward background to it um it
was unusual in that I didn't think that
members in fusing planning permission
had gained a full a sufficiently full
appreciation of the material of the
change thank you are there any
questions no thank you very much thank
you
and nothing further to thank you thank
you okay are there any questions for the
[Music]
officer no um I'll move the floor to
debate if we so wish one Council
Armitage yes thank you chair well I
looked at this uh when I first looked at
this uh uh the little house it was
photographed as such where it was uh
all it all it showed was a field behind
it in open Countryside and it looked
like sort of like Little House on the
Prairie it didn't show on the
presentation all the trees because there
were only whips at that time but uh you
know when I visited the site with
councel Elliot I could see that planted
trees all the way around and uh you know
it fitted that in the the next sort of
three or four years these trees would
come up and they were offing lots of
sites with Wildlife VI diversity uh and
the the uh Little House fitted in
beautifully and it looked
superb okay thank you councelor Elliot
thank you
chair and the the only thing I'd like to
add to what councelor Armitage has said
is the first time this came up the the
photo that was submitted and probably
gave the illusion that that this was a a
huge bar that that had G stuck up in the
middle of the field with absolutely no
consideration for anybody where the
truth of the matter was the the photos
were disingenuous they were zoomed in
right close up to the place and the
three that I've seen today that the
officers have shown are more more in
keeping with a with a proper eye view of
from the from the boundaries and and
from close up that give the real
impression of what it's
like uh and and once this once this
landscaping and the and the whips have
grown as Council says you'll not even
see it but in the whole scheme of things
in in 60 or more Acres you can't see the
thing and and and just to add to that
that building was actually going to be
so much closer to the charlest toown
boundary uh and it was moved at the at
the uh
objectors not even request it was moved
so he could have a better
view that that for me is just about sums
up the application so yeah I know where
I should be voting councilor Foster and
then I'll have a comment thank you chair
um I won't like this I won't like it to
go by without mentioning the comments
that on page 140 under 4.4 uh ashover
Parish Council recognizes the initial
committee decision uh but the proposal
is not supported under policies ap2 ap13
and
ap19 um that's at the bottom of page 140
so taking the earlier remonstration by
Mr field send on the Chain about about
what we can and what we can't ask I'll
ask uh planning officers if if they
could enlighten me uh as to AP to ap13
and ap19 and now it doesn't it's not
supported by that by that plan thank
you okay before we go and ask that
question I've just got to actually
confirm everything that councilor ellot
has seen I have visited this site with
councilor Elliot and I've also walked
the public boundary with um my family
this site is amazing and actually even
now you cannot see that house or call it
what you will Little House on the
Prairie from the foot path it is an
absolutely outstanding
sight so I will be supporting officers
recommendations but we before that we'll
ask
for Mark to ask question
clarification I just opening the a
neighborhood plan just give me two
seconds okay just while Alice is is
catching
on that have things to say to further to
what are we saying but um AP1 of the ash
over a plan relates to proposals outside
the limits to development and they
are seeking within that policy the
ashover neighborhood plan to ensure that
new development is sympathetic to the
character appearance of the countryside
in this instance and
are in the same vein as your your own
local fund policies in that respect
um policy ap13 relates to landscape
character and is similar in field to
policy
ap2 and then looking to protect enhance
the character of landscape character of
areas whilst policy ap19 relates to dark
skies and seeks to ensure that new
development doesn't impact on the Dark
Skies of ashover and just just on those
points chair officers in reporting on
the first application of replicated that
in this application and we are of the
view as your officers that what is
proposed is sympathetic to the character
of the area the fishing ponds certainly
are um sorry not the fishing ponds but
the ponds whether they being used for
fishing or not are a character of the
country that you see around various
parts of Northeast arer and aren't in
the view of offices in themselves
outside protecting that character and in
this instance um You could argue that
there's an enhancement in terms of
what's been said to you about ecology in
terms of the the
building bearing in mind that a building
was granted consent on the site some
years ago and it's not been constructed
in accordance with that as members will
be aware but as a building has been
approved on the site there is that
fallback position officers retain The
View that the Amendments and alterations
proposed are not so different from that
as who lead us to a different conclusion
and if it were used for an alternative
purpose whether it be to support a
commercial fishery or for other purposes
that will be controlled by requirement
for planning consent in its own right
and members would of course have the
opportunity to assess and consider that
at planning committee I hope that's
helpful to to yourselves chair I don't
know if Alice's got anything that she
would wish to add but pass over to her
if she has thanks I just um add about
the do Skies uh you'll notice that there
is a condition uh prohibiting use of um
lights on the outside of the building
and that's for that reason otherwise we
were of the opinion that the um the
proposal does meet the requirements of
those policies from the ashover
neighborhood plan as Aid has
explained than you CH thank
you I'm going to move then that we go
for motion and I will propose this
motion and I'll second it chair thank
you so we'll now go for the vote thank
you chair councilor Armitage for Council
Barker for councelor cl for councelor
Cooper councelor Elliot for councelor
foster counc hardson for Council
liit four councilor Powell Council
four and Council Wiley for that's
unanimous chair
carried my button thank you very much
gentlemen safe
journey just going to find my agenda and
I think we' bound to the last item which
isend item 11 which is the
appeal
no that's it chair planning appeals
right thank you
Adrian very very little to report this
month shair it's been another quiet
month there been the two appeals handed
down the um one that was allowed at aill
Lane and the other chair is the
first High hedge appeal that I can
recall um and it's again it was part L
part ofuse but and in general terms
chair it supported the decision that was
taken by the council in that there's a
significant reduction in the Hedge
required the difference between the
officer decision and the inspector
decision is that the head retention
height is just increased by
approximately 30 cmers so again chair it
is validation of the the process and the
way we dealt with the application if
there any questions CH have to be
taken
okay I'm not sure who that was but are
there any
questions no thank you very much
Adrian okay I have no urgent business
other than to wish you all a very merry
and happy and healthy Christmas and I'll
see you all in the new
year